Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同举办的“经常性收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, are you ready to unravel the secrets of pensions as a mental health professional and inspiring psychologist? Join us in this very special
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，你准备好作为一名心理健康专业人士和有抱负的心理学家，去揭开养老金的秘密了吗？欢迎加入我们这期非常特别的
episode where I'm joined by a qualified independent financial advisor where we go through all things pension. Loads of great advice in there and answering all of your questions. Tune in and equip yourself with all of the skills, advice and strategy you need to be liberated in your financial freedom in future. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Something I really struggled with when I was earlier in my career was feeling like a proper enough grown-up to take myself seriously and look at pensions. It was something that was always on my to-do list but never really seemed like the right time. I'm
节目，我邀请了一位合格的独立财务顾问，我们将深入探讨养老金的所有相关事宜。节目中包含了大量实用的建议，并解答了你们所有的问题。请收听节目，掌握未来实现财务自由所需的技能、建议和策略。希望这期节目对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。在我职业生涯早期，我曾非常纠结，觉得自己还不够成熟，无法认真对待自己并去研究养老金。这曾是我待办事项清单上的一项，但似乎总觉得时机未到。我
telling you now is the right time but I know that can still feel tricky. Previously for episode 76 I was joined by Ian Dempsey, an independent financial advisor and we were talking generally about money and trying to make ends meet and having it stretch to cover our bases, but also to kind of think about financial planning. I've invited him back by special request where we're going to be looking specifically at pensions. This is ideal if you are any kind of mental health professional and if you are a qualified or an unqualified member of staff. Let's dive in and meet Ian again. And yeah, I will catch you on the other side. Today, we have Ian Dempsey with us, who you might remember, a few months back,
现在告诉你，时机到了，但我知道这仍然让人感到棘手。在第76期节目中，我邀请了独立财务顾问Ian Dempsey，我们讨论了关于金钱的一般性话题，试图维持收支平衡，在满足基本需求的同时，也开始考虑财务规划。应听众特别要求，我再次邀请了他，这次我们将专门探讨养老金。如果你是任何类型的心理健康专业人士，无论你是合格的还是非合格的员工，这期节目都非常适合你。让我们开始吧，再次欢迎Ian。是的，稍后见。今天，我们邀请到了Ian Dempsey，大家可能还记得，几个月前，
we were talking about all things money. And we have a special request for Ian to come back and talk about pensions today. Hian thank you for joining us hello you're very welcome i mean yes come on come on back again we should make it a regular start really shouldn't we i think yeah i think so many of us don't really understand money that that's probably not a bad idea and i think part of the challenge we've got at the minute as we just said i fear it's really challenging to look after your money at the moment. It costs the living. Investment markets aren't performing particularly well. Interest rates are doing great guns at the moment, but that could be a double-edged sword with your mortgage going up.
我们讨论了关于金钱的一切。应听众特别要求，Ian今天回来专门谈谈养老金。Ian，谢谢你加入我们。你好，非常欢迎。没错，我们确实应该把它变成一个常态，不是吗？我想是的，我们很多人并不真正了解金钱，这可能不是个坏主意。我认为我们目前面临的挑战之一，正如我们刚才所说，现在管理财务确实非常具有挑战性。生活成本在上升，投资市场表现并不特别理想。利率目前很高，但这可能是一把双刃剑，因为你的抵押贷款成本也在增加。
But potentially you're getting a bigger return on your savings account. Like I think I said to you, I've been doing this for 17 years now and these economic conditions we're in right now are the worst i've seen in 17 years and it's just a real mix of emotion challenging circumstances it's tough like it's really really hard to manage your money at the moment i think right across the board no matter what level of wealth or where you are in your career journey it's hard it It's really, really tough. Yeah, I couldn't agree more. I couldn't agree more.
但潜在地，你的储蓄账户可能会获得更高的回报。就像我之前对你说的，我从事这一行已经17年了，我们目前所处的经济环境是我17年来见过的最糟糕的。这真的是一种情绪和挑战性环境的混合体，目前管理财务真的非常非常困难。我认为无论你的财富水平如何，或者你处于职业生涯的哪个阶段，这都是困难的。这真的非常非常艰难。是的，我完全同意。我完全同意。
And I guess we just have to hope it will. You know, what we know about is it bull and bear years that we will get back up there again and things will improve. I mean, it will, 100%. Like, if you look at history and as much as the FCSA past performance is an indication of the future, every single time we go through this, it gets better. It's just holding your nerve
我想我们只能希望情况会好转。你知道，我们所知道的是，无论是牛市还是熊市，我们最终都会回升，情况会改善。我的意思是，百分之百会。如果你看看历史，尽管过去的表现不能保证未来，但每一次我们经历这些，情况都会好转。关键在于保持冷静，
and staying consistent with your approach. That's what makes a big difference long-term. But that's easier said than done if maybe this is the time that you've just started. And I think part of the challenge we've got is we've had good markets for 10 years. We've had good returns, solid returns for a long period of time
并坚持你的策略。这就是长期来看产生巨大差异的原因。但如果你刚刚起步，这说起来容易做起来难。我认为我们面临的挑战之一是，过去10年我们经历了良好的市场。我们在很长一段时间内获得了良好的、稳健的回报，
while interest rates have been low having conversations about investments and pensions has been a very very easy conversation because you can just pull those figures out and just compare the two now it's it's very very different and i've got clients in investments as i kind of mentioned off air that that are just unsure whether it's the right thing for them long term 100% is but right now is it the right thing so there's some real challenges and some difficult conversations kind of happening behind the scenes at the moment yeah yeah there are and it really does make me think about when I was in a position that was probably quite fortunate I I won't lie, when I was working full-time as an assistant psychologist and I was living with my parents. I think I only paid about £100 a month rent. It was
而在利率较低的时候，讨论投资和养老金是非常容易的，因为你可以直接拿出那些数字进行比较。现在情况非常非常不同了。正如我在节目外提到的，我的一些客户在投资方面感到不确定，不知道这是否是他们的长期最佳选择。百分之百是，但就目前而言，这是正确的做法吗？所以目前幕后确实存在一些真正的挑战和困难的对话。是的，确实如此。这让我想起我曾经处于一个可能相当幸运的位置。我不撒谎，当我全职担任助理心理学家并与父母住在一起时，我想我每月只付大约100英镑的房租。那真的
very, very low-key. And I really probably at that point was thinking, should I start a pension? Shouldn't I start a pension? And I guess other people listening to this might well be having that similar feeling. So I think I'm right in saying that if you're employed, you kind of have to be offered a workplace pension. Is that right, Ian? It is, absolutely. So auto enrolment came in a few years back, which effectively became a legal requirement for employers initially of a certain size, and then it's just been phased out to smaller and smaller employers to offer a pension. And the minimum contribution of that pension in total is 8%. So that would be 5% from you,
非常非常低。当时我可能真的在想，我应该开始存养老金吗？我不应该开始存养老金吗？我想听节目的其他人可能也有类似的感觉。所以我想我没说错吧，如果你是受雇的，雇主必须为你提供工作场所养老金，对吗，Ian？是的，绝对正确。所以自动加入机制（auto enrolment）是几年前推出的，它实际上成为了雇主的一项法律要求，最初是针对一定规模的雇主，然后逐渐推广到越来越小的雇主，要求他们提供养老金。养老金的总缴费比例最低为8%。这意味着你个人缴纳5%，
3% from your employer. But it's very easy for you to opt out of it. You could say, I don't want to be part of that pension. I don't want to do it. It's when you're kind of young, free, and you've got the world at your feet. Do you really think about a pension? No, you don't. I didn't. And I'm just going to start a little bit later. But I think in the 17 years I've been doing this, when I look at the experience of clients
你的雇主缴纳3%。但你很容易选择退出。你可以说，我不想参加那个养老金计划。我不想做。当你年轻、自由、前途无量的时候，你会真的考虑养老金吗？不，你不会。我当时就没有。我只是打算晚一点再开始。但我认为在我从事这一行的17年里，当我观察那些
that have got to a really strong retirement position or have got significant wealth built up for later on in life they started early and they didn't start with massive amounts because that compound effect over a period of time just spirals and spirals and gets bigger and bigger and those margins of contribution levels to growth get wider and wider every single time so start as soon as you possibly can even if it's only just a relatively small amount it makes a big difference long term and ultimately the way you've got to think about it in simple terms is if you put £100 in your employer's going to top that up then you're going to get your tax relief on top of that straight away off the bat you've got well over a 30% to 40% uplift. If I could get clients 30%, 40% uplift on investments, I'd be retired by now because I'd be doing the same.
在退休时处于非常稳固地位，或者为晚年积累了大量财富的客户时，他们都是尽早开始的。他们并不是从巨额资金开始的，因为复利效应在一段时间内会不断螺旋式上升，变得越来越大，而且缴费水平与增长之间的差距也会越来越大。所以尽可能早地开始，即使金额相对较小，长期来看也会产生巨大的差异。归根结底，简单来说，如果你投入100英镑，你的雇主会为你补足，然后你还会立即获得税收减免。从一开始，你就获得了超过30%到40%的收益。如果我能让客户在投资上获得30%到40%的收益，我现在早就退休了，因为我会做同样的事情。
You know, that's an incredible free uplift to your savings or investments that you don't get on an ISA, you don't get on a savings account, you don't get deductions against your mortgage for that. Tax relief at 20% as a basic rate taxpayer, 40% at higher rates, plus an employer contribution is huge. Make the most of it. Because if you don't, in simple terms, that money just stays with your employer. That just becomes their profit, does it? They just put that back into their own coffers. Absolutely. And there's no obligation for them to do that if you've opted out of that scheme because you've made the decision. You've decided, I don't want to be part of this scheme,
你知道，这是对你的储蓄或投资的一笔不可思议的免费提升，你在ISA（个人储蓄账户）中得不到，在储蓄账户中得不到，在抵押贷款中也得不到这种扣除。作为基本税率纳税人，20%的税收减免，高税率下为40%，再加上雇主的缴费，这非常巨大。一定要充分利用它。因为如果你不这样做，简单来说，那笔钱就留在了你的雇主那里。那变成了他们的利润，对吗？他们只是把它放回了自己的金库。绝对是这样。如果你因为自己的决定而选择了退出该计划，他们就没有义务这样做。你决定了，我不想参加这个计划，
therefore I'm going to step back. Some of the bigger companies will say, well, we'll give you an extra £150 a month on your salary or whatever it might be. They'll compensate you for that. But a lot of them won't. They'll just say, well, okay, that's fine, no problem. But the sooner you start, the bigger those those numbers are much further down the line and it also
因此我要退出。一些大公司会说，好吧，我们会给你的工资增加150英镑，或者其他什么金额。他们会补偿你。但很多公司不会。他们只会说，好吧，没问题。但你开始得越早，那些数字在未来就会越大，而且它也
fundamentally means that when you get to your 40s and 50s you're not having to play catch up to to make up for those early years yeah there's two things i want to talk to you about which aren't linked to pensions but i'm going to to ask you anyway, because it's made me think. About a month ago, we were talking about compound interest, because I'd shared a post on socials that said, if I was to give you one penny a day that will double every day for the next 31 days, or I was to give you a million pounds today, which would you take? And most of us think, you wouldn't, I know what you'd take. The answer was like, of course I'd take a million pounds, because one P a day doubled for 31 days. That's what's going to give me about four pounds or something, isn't it? That'd be rubbish. But actually actually you're much better off with the one p a day and
从根本上意味着当你到了40多岁和50多岁时，你不必为了弥补早年的缺失而苦苦追赶。是的，有两件事我想和你谈谈，它们与养老金无关，但我还是要问你，因为这让我想到了。大约一个月前，我们谈到了复利，因为我在社交媒体上分享了一篇文章，上面说，如果我每天给你一便士，并且在接下来的31天里每天翻倍，或者我今天给你一百万英镑，你会选哪一个？我们大多数人会想，你不会，我知道你会选什么。答案是，当然我会选一百万英镑，因为一便士每天翻倍31天，那只会给我大约四英镑左右，不是吗？那太烂了。但实际上，你选择每天一便士会好得多，
that in essence is how compound interest works isn't it can you guide us through that better than i just have ian yeah absolutely so it's it's a it's a it's a great way just illustrate a simple compact and that the phrase that i always use is einstein said it was the eighth wonder of the world so compound growth is just growth on your on your on your growth so day one you put 100 pound in so let's assume day two you've got 102 pound on day three you would get growth on that 100 plus the two so it's growth on growth on growth and I think the interesting part is the longer you have that money in there, the bigger that growth is going to be, which is where certainly when you look at pensions and investments for clients,
这本质上就是复利的工作原理，不是吗？你能比我刚才更好地引导我们了解这一点吗，Ian？是的，绝对可以。这是一个说明简单复利的绝佳方式，我总是引用爱因斯坦的话，他说这是世界第八大奇迹。所以复利增长就是你增长基础上的增长。第一天你投入100英镑，假设第二天你有102英镑，第三天你将在那100英镑加上2英镑的基础上获得增长，所以它是增长之上的增长。我认为有趣的部分是，你持有这笔钱的时间越长，增长就会越大，这当然也是我在为客户审视养老金和投资时所看到的，
it's a case of thinking, well, you might not be there now, but stick with it because those last few years before you need that, that compound growth can be phenomenal. But going back to your example, it's just sit down, sit down, write it on a sheet of paper. So a penny, then it goes to two, then it goes to example, it's just sit down, sit down, write it on a sheet of paper. So a penny, then it goes to two, then it goes to, then it'll go to four, then it'll go to eight, then it'll go to, and it just grows and grows and grows over a period of time. And even I was amazed when I kind of looked at that one. I thought, wow, that's a big number
这是一个需要思考的问题，好吧，你现在可能还没到那个阶段，但坚持下去，因为在你需要那笔钱之前的最后几年，复利增长可能是惊人的。但回到你的例子，只需坐下来，拿出一张纸写下来。一便士，然后变成两便士，然后变成四便士，然后变成八便士，然后……它在一段时间内不断增长。即使是我在看到那个数字时也感到惊讶。我想，哇，那是一个巨大的数字
at the end of it. But that's the kind of stuff that can either work with you or can work against you. And when I say work against you, that is things like debt, credit card loans, compound growth is working against you. But if you put it working for you in savings accounts, even at the moment, because the interest rates are really good or investments, you're getting growth on your growth. So your money is working hard for you. And a phrase that I always use is when you save your money, you put it to rest. When you invest your money, you put it out to work. So you're sending out the packed lunch ready to go and you're building money
在最后。但这正是那种既可以为你所用，也可以对你不利的东西。当我说是对你不利时，指的是债务、信用卡贷款，复利在对你不利。但如果你把它用在储蓄账户中，即使在目前，因为利率非常好，或者投资中，你是在获得增长的增长。所以你的钱在为你努力工作。我总是用的一句话是：当你存钱时，你让钱休息；当你投资时，你让钱去工作。所以你是在把打包好的午餐送出去，让它去为你积累更多的钱。
on your money. And over a period of time, it makes such a difference. I absolutely love that. Go on money. Off you go. Go and work hard and bring me some more back. The other thing I wanted to talk to you about is probably something that's already on your radar. It's something I heard on Radio 2 recently.
随着时间的推移，这会产生巨大的差异。我绝对喜欢这个说法。去吧，钱。去努力工作，带回更多给我。我想和你谈的另一件事可能是你已经关注到的。这是我最近在Radio 2上听到的。
I'm a Radio 2 girl. And they were talking about, you know, when you're in a supermarket and it says, or even for that matter, McDonald's, and they say, oh, do you want to round it up to give to charity? You know, give an extra 25p. And I've always thought oh that's a nice thing for them to do isn't it and sometimes I do and sometimes I don't what I didn't realize and I might I might have grasped the conversation wrong is that that becomes a tax break for the company that's not necessarily as altruistic as that might look
我是Radio 2的忠实听众。他们当时在谈论，你知道，当你在超市，甚至是麦当劳时，他们说，哦，你想凑个整捐给慈善机构吗？你知道，多捐25便士。我一直认为，哦，这对他们来说是一件好事，不是吗？有时我会捐，有时不会。我没有意识到的是——我可能误解了那段对话——这实际上成为了公司的税收减免，这并不一定像看起来那么无私。
and that's something that I wasn't aware of, and I would probably assume most people are not. Is that right? 100% it is, yeah, absolutely. So they get a deduction for any charitable contributions against their corporation tax bill. They don't get above and beyond that. So if you said, I'm going to give you 25p in my pound
这是我之前不知道的，我可能认为大多数人也不知道。这是真的吗？百分之百是真的，是的，绝对是。所以他们可以从公司税单中扣除任何慈善捐款。他们得到的不仅仅是这些。所以如果你说，我要给你25便士，
to go towards the McDonald's charities, then they just get a tax break on that part that goes in they don't get extra relief on top of it for doing it um but yeah that that's that's what it's there for but i can remember i used to work in mcdonald's a long long time ago and they were at the time they're one of the biggest charities in the world because of the amount of money that they they donate to kids charities i think they do a phenomenal job but at the same time that's something that you could benefit from like if there are charities that are close to your heart rather than contributing to them personally you could contribute to them through your business and you could you could legitimately write some
去支持麦当劳的慈善机构，那么他们只是在那部分捐款上获得了税收减免，他们并没有因为这样做而获得额外的额外减免。但这就是它的存在目的。但我记得我很久以前在麦当劳工作过，当时他们是世界上最大的慈善机构之一，因为他们向儿童慈善机构捐赠的金额。我认为他们做得非常出色，但同时，这也是你可以利用的事情。如果有一些慈善机构是你心之所向的，与其个人捐款，你可以通过你的企业捐款，你可以合法地将其中一些
of that off as as um as a taxable expense like make the most of it you know it's contribute out your business so people are already limited companies then they can look to do that in their own business and then benefit the charities that they want to benefit yeah absolutely okay how many stars did you get on your badge ian oh great question i had this is the old school i had the full house i had five so so i did a bit of everything. Honestly, I talked to people at McDonald's. It was a great...
作为应纳税支出注销。充分利用它，你知道，从你的企业中捐款。所以如果人们已经是有限公司，他们可以考虑在自己的企业中这样做，从而造福他们想要支持的慈善机构。是的，绝对可以。好的，Ian，你的徽章上有多少颗星？哦，好问题。这是老派的做法，我拿到了满分，我有五颗星，所以我什么都做过。老实说，我和麦当劳的人交谈过。那是一个很棒的……
I loved McDonald's when I worked there. It was a really busy branch. And it just... They got the monies with that, absolutely. But I loved it. I think it was such a great ground to do so many things that I kind of look at now. Because you were just in at the deep end
我在麦当劳工作时很喜欢那里。那是一个非常繁忙的分店。他们确实得到了那些钱，绝对的。但我喜欢它。我认为这是一个非常好的基础，可以做很多我现在回想起来的事情。因为你直接被扔进了深水区，
and you worked really, really hard for eight-hour shifts. Stunk of burgers at the end of it which which my parents never liked but there you go one of my besties when I was at uni used to work at McDonald's during the school um holidays as well and um we used to like to play a game how bored we were sometimes what do McDonald's ever run out of let's do they ever run out of gherkins no do they ever run out of? Do they ever run out of gherkins? No. Do they ever run out of buns? No. Literally, the answer was no for everything. But I think things have changed these days.
并且为了八小时的轮班努力工作。最后身上全是汉堡的味道，我父母从来不喜欢这样，但这就是生活。我在大学时最好的朋友之一在学校假期期间也在麦当劳工作，我们有时喜欢玩一个游戏，看看我们有多无聊。麦当劳会用完什么吗？他们会用完酸黄瓜吗？不。他们会用完什么？他们会用完酸黄瓜吗？不。他们会用完面包吗？不。字面上，答案对所有东西都是“不”。但我想现在情况变了。
They often don't have things these days. But, yeah, that's a little insight into my life when I was at uni. Also, they're a really good employer. They do private health care for their staff, which you just wouldn't know, probably. And degree. You can get a degree now through McDonald's. I'm reading, I've read a great book. It was called Sympological Repeatable, which is one of the former directors of McDonald's in the US.
他们现在经常缺货。但这就是我大学生活的一点缩影。而且，他们是一个非常好的雇主。他们为员工提供私人医疗保险，你可能根本不知道。还有学位。你现在可以通过麦当劳获得学位。我正在读一本很棒的书，叫《简单、逻辑、可重复》（Simple, Logical, Repeatable），这是麦当劳美国前任董事之一写的。
And she wrote a book around how processes will have to find your business and it's so true because mcdonald's are really really good at what they do because you get the same cheeseburger no matter where in the world you get it because it's a simple logical repeatable process and they've just refined and refined and refined that down to something that distilled it to something really pure and every single branch follows the same process every employee goes through the same process their training is exceptional because they want everybody to do it in a specific way um they've they've done phenomenally well out of it i don't know whether you saw you've seen the um the the film with michael keaton in it
她写了一本书，关于流程如何定义你的业务，这太真实了，因为麦当劳在他们所做的事情上真的非常非常出色，因为无论你在世界哪个地方，你得到的芝士汉堡都是一样的，因为它是一个简单、逻辑、可重复的流程。他们已经将其提炼、提炼、再提炼到一种非常纯粹的东西，每一家分店都遵循相同的流程，每一位员工都经历相同的流程，他们的培训非常出色，因为他们希望每个人都以特定的方式去做。他们做得非常成功。我不知道你是否看过迈克尔·基顿主演的那部电影，
when he's that he's the ray Kroc the founder of McDonald's and he gets involved with these two brilliant film love that film but yeah there's so much to be learned from it they've done phenomenally well they're a worldwide chain and continue to grow so one of the questions I've received was given the kind of uncertainty of what a career in mental health might look like these days. So it might involve NHS or employed work. It might involve a bit of private work. It might involve fully being private. Should people or could people consider, should they not have any NHS pension?
他饰演麦当劳的创始人雷·克洛克（Ray Kroc），他与这两个人接触……很棒的电影，我喜欢那部电影。但确实，有很多东西可以从中学习。他们做得非常成功，他们是一个全球连锁店，并且在持续增长。所以，我收到的一个问题是，考虑到如今心理健康职业的不确定性。它可能涉及NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）或受雇工作。它可能涉及一些私人工作。它可能完全是私人执业。人们应该或可以考虑，如果他们没有任何NHS养老金，他们应该怎么做？
Should they start a private pension right away? Or I know it's kind of hard to give generic advice, but people are confused, Ian. What's the way forward? Yeah. I think that's in the whole of the market about pensions. Like pensions have this illusion that they're really complicated. But if you look at the NHS pension, it's still a very, very good pension scheme. So I would encourage anybody that has access to that pension scheme to have one because it's such a well-rounded, great growth on the scheme itself, depending on which variation of the scheme that you're involved in. But even the most recent one, which I think was the 2015 edition. I can't remember off the top of my head,
他们应该立即开始私人养老金吗？或者我知道给出一般性建议很难，但人们感到困惑，Ian。前进的方向是什么？是的。我认为这是关于养老金的整个市场的问题。养老金有一种错觉，认为它们非常复杂。但如果你看看NHS养老金，它仍然是一个非常非常好的养老金计划。所以我鼓励任何有权使用该养老金计划的人都加入一个，因为它是一个非常全面、增长良好的计划，具体取决于你参与的是哪种变体。但即使是最近的一个，我想是2015年版的。我记不清了，
but there's three different evolutions of the NHS pension. And no matter which evolution you're involved in, you're not going to get that kind of growth. You're not going to get that kind of return over a consistent basis as you would do with a private pension. But that doesn't mean to say that a private pension hasn't got its place. So ultimately, if you are thinking that you want to move up from the NHS to private practice,
但NHS养老金有三种不同的演变。无论你参与的是哪种演变，你都不会获得那种增长。你不会像私人养老金那样获得持续的基础回报。但这并不意味着私人养老金没有它的位置。所以归根结底，如果你认为你想从NHS转到私人执业，
there are pros and cons for both of them. What I encourage psychologists and people that work in this space that I have conversations with is to think about the bigger picture, first of all. It's not just about the pension. It's about the big piece. It's what do you want to get out of life? What are your financial goals? What do you want to achieve?
两者都有利弊。我鼓励心理学家和在这个领域工作的人，我与他们交谈时，首先要考虑大局。这不仅仅是关于养老金。这是关于大局。你从生活中想要得到什么？你的财务目标是什么？你想实现什么？
Why is that so important to you and plan that all out and get a real structure that works that you're emotionally engaged with first and then the numbers can just drop in because it might be that you've got enough pension provision where you are after being in the nhs for 10 or 15 years that you don't necessarily want to have a private pension there might be other things you want to do it might be that you've got a shortfall so you want to make that up by making those contributions and keeping your corporation tax below a certain level everybody's different but what i'd encourage anybody to do is have some conversations with a financial advisor have some conversations with an accountant talk these things through
为什么这对你如此重要？把这一切都规划好，建立一个你情感上投入的真正结构，然后数字自然就会落到实处。可能你在NHS工作了10或15年后，现有的养老金储备已经足够了，你并不一定需要私人养老金。可能还有其他你想做的事情。也可能你有缺口，所以你想通过缴费来弥补，并将你的公司税保持在一定水平以下。每个人都不同，但我鼓励任何人与财务顾问进行一些对话，与会计师进行一些对话，讨论这些事情，
talk to colleagues talk to other people in this position to understand what they do i think the nhs have got a great health plan that you can get in contact with with the pension the information might be limited um but it's a good starting point like most financial advisors will have a conversation with you around what's the right thing to do and i'd like to think the majority of them would be would indeed come back with that right advice for you yeah thank you and you can absolutely have both can't you can have an NHS and a private and also a child can have a pension you can start saving a pension for a child can't you literally it's never too soon yeah absolutely and I think if you can start contributing to a pension for your kids at an early age, you're setting themselves up for such a great retirement further down the line. And as I said earlier, start and earlier makes such a difference.
与同事和其他处于这个位置的人交谈，了解他们是怎么做的。我认为NHS有一个很棒的健康计划，你可以联系养老金部门，信息可能有限，但这是一个很好的起点。大多数财务顾问都会和你讨论什么是正确的做法，我愿意相信他们中的大多数确实会为你提供正确的建议。是的，谢谢。而且你绝对可以两者兼得，不是吗？你可以同时拥有NHS和私人养老金，而且孩子也可以有养老金，你可以开始为孩子存养老金，不是吗？字面上，永远不会太早。是的，绝对可以。而且我认为如果你能尽早开始为你的孩子缴纳养老金，你就是在为他们未来的退休生活打下坚实的基础。正如我之前所说，尽早开始会产生巨大的差异。
If you could get them started from what they wouldn't start from birth, like parents or grandparents contributed from birth, you could do 2 do 2880 a year with tax relief that goes up to 3600 um if you contributed to that and they then contributed 100 pound a month for the rest of their life they're the kind of people that retire at the age of 55 and and the rest of us are kind of kind of working it makes such a difference but having that discipline of 100 pound a month rather than getting to 40 and 50 £50 and realising you've got some serious shortfalls to make up makes such a difference. And if people are listening thinking I'd love to be able to find an extra £100 a month to put in my kids pension but I haven't got that but I could probably muster up a tenner a month is that worth doing or not? Yeah whatever you can
如果你能让他们从出生就开始，比如父母或祖父母从出生就开始缴费，你每年可以存2880英镑，加上税收减免，总额可达3600英镑。如果你投入了这些，然后他们余生每月投入100英镑，他们就是那种55岁就能退休的人，而我们其他人还在工作。这会产生巨大的差异。但拥有每月100英镑的纪律，而不是到了40岁、50岁才意识到你需要弥补严重的缺口，这会产生巨大的差异。如果人们听了之后想，我很想每月多存100英镑到我孩子的养老金里，但我没有那么多，但我可能能凑出每月10英镑，这样做值得吗？是的，无论你能
do I think I think investments and pensions are a lot more accessible than they ever have been i think the information that's available especially with social media and webinars youtube places like that there is a vast amount of information available on the basics and i think you almost need to distill it down to what what the basic elements are and it's or do you want to save for your's, do you want to save for your kid's future? Do you want to save for your future? Yes or no? Simple as that. And then you can kind of plan out.
做什么，我认为投资和养老金比以往任何时候都更容易获得。我认为可获得的信息，特别是通过社交媒体、网络研讨会、YouTube等地方，关于基础知识的信息非常多。我认为你几乎需要将其提炼为基本要素，即：你想为你的未来存钱吗？你想为孩子的未来存钱吗？你想为你的未来存钱吗？是还是不是？就这么简单。然后你就可以进行规划了。
You don't necessarily have to start with a massive amount. It could be that you start, like you said, with a tenner, that maybe you build up in a savings account. And then once a year, you make a contribution into the pension. I'm not sure many investment platforms operate at only a 10 or a month i think the minimum tends to be about 25 but two and a half months in you can you can make a contribution you could do that three four five times a year if you wanted to but just just get started and start chipping away makes a big difference brilliant such good advice and when i left the
你不一定非要从巨额资金开始。可能就像你说的，从10英镑开始，也许你先在储蓄账户中积累。然后每年一次，你向养老金账户缴费。我不确定有多少投资平台只接受每月10英镑，我认为最低限额通常在25英镑左右，但每两个半月你就可以进行一次缴费，如果你愿意，一年可以做三、四、五次。但只要开始，一点一点地积累，就会产生巨大的差异。太棒了，真是很好的建议。当我离开
nhs you know it's that quandary of what do I do with it? Do I leave it there? Do I kind of take it out and put it in my in my new shiny private pension? And I think the general consensus is leave it there. Leave it there. You're not going to do much better than an NHS pension. Is that kind of your general advice? Yeah, 100 percent. I mean, you can't you can't move it out anyway so it has to stay within the NHS I think um one of the dangers that you can kind of overlook is you can almost kind of disregard that and start really going aggressively after your um your
NHS时，你知道，那是关于我该怎么处理它的困境？我把它留在那里吗？我把它取出来放到我新的闪亮的私人养老金里吗？我认为普遍的共识是留在那里。留在那里。你不会比NHS养老金做得更好。这是你的一般建议吗？是的，百分之百。我的意思是，无论如何你都不能把它转出来，所以它必须留在NHS内。我认为，你可能会忽略的一个危险是，你可能会几乎忽略它，并开始非常激进地追求你的
private pension and contributing consistently on a consistent basis over a period of time, take a step back, big picture stuff that has to be included in that conversation. If you're having a conversation with a financial advisor and all they're talking about is the private pension, but they're not including this NHS pension that you've got, which could be worth quite a tidy sum of money, then maybe you need to be having conversations with a different financial advisor. And that's not me saying that, it has to be having conversations with a different financial advisor. And that's not me saying that. It has to be me or anybody else. But big picture stuff, you need to plan the whole thing out.
私人养老金，并在此期间持续缴费。退后一步，大局观必须包含在对话中。如果你正在与财务顾问交谈，而他们只谈论私人养老金，却没有包括你拥有的这个可能价值不菲的NHS养老金，那么也许你需要与不同的财务顾问交谈。这不是我说的，而是你需要与不同的财务顾问交谈。这不是我或其他人说的。但大局观，你需要规划整个事情。
It's not just looking at one particular area. And yes, those private contributions are worth it long term. But how do you know you haven't got enough already? Because if you have got enough already, could you do something else? Could you be spending it could you be going on holiday two or three times a year instead of paying that pension that's why the big picture conversation makes such a difference retirement plan is really important 100 but it's that million dollar question of getting a balance between now and what you want further down the line and somewhere in the middle is the right answer. And that balance will tip and kind of sway throughout your life.
这不仅仅是看某一个特定领域。是的，那些私人缴费长期来看是值得的。但你怎么知道你还没有足够的钱呢？因为如果你已经足够了，你可以做点别的吗？你可以把它花掉吗？你可以一年去度假两三次，而不是支付那笔养老金吗？这就是为什么大局观对话会产生如此大的差异。退休计划非常重要，百分之百，但这是一个价值百万美元的问题，即在现在和未来你想要的东西之间取得平衡，而中间的某个地方就是正确答案。这种平衡会在你的一生中倾斜和摇摆。
And sometimes I tell clients to just spend the money and it kind of puts them on a bit of the back foot. But if you've got enough, then why do you need more? Spend it, enjoy life because tomorrow is not guaranteed, is it? No, it isn't. And I've not read the book, but i know there's a book called is it die broke or something like that that you basically plan so much that you're you know you haven't really got anything left to pass on when you're when you're gone yeah i've heard i can't
有时我告诉客户直接把钱花掉，这让他们有点措手不及。但如果你已经足够了，为什么还需要更多？花掉它，享受生活，因为明天是不确定的，不是吗？不，确实不是。我没读过那本书，但我知道有一本书叫《死时破产》（Die Broke）之类的，你基本上规划得太多，以至于当你离开时，你真的没有什么可以留下的了。是的，我听说过，我不能
remember the exact name of it but i don't think it's something along those lines yes it's definitely on the list but yeah absolutely like you can't take it with you i mean great that you want to leave stuff for the kids i understand that as well because actually it's giving them a bit of a leg up further down the line but i'm sure your kids and i'll say this exactly for my parents i'd prefer them to be around for another 10 or 15 years because i've had a great old life rather than scrimping saving and leave me 50 60 grand in a will spend it i don't need it absolutely i wish i could have kept my dad for longer you know he worked hard and he worked as a boiler man and um you know he did
记得它的确切名字，但我想是类似的意思。是的，它肯定在清单上。但绝对是这样，你带不走它。我的意思是，你想给孩子们留下东西很好，我也理解这一点，因为实际上这是在未来给他们一点帮助。但我相信你的孩子——我也会为我的父母这样说——我宁愿他们再多活10或15年，因为我过得很好，而不是省吃俭用，在遗嘱里给我留下5万或6万英镑。花掉它，我不需要它。绝对是这样，我真希望我能让父亲多陪我一会儿。你知道，他工作很努力，他是一名锅炉工，而且……你知道，他
did enjoy his life he liked tinkering with his bikes and stuff but he died at 71 and that's no age no not at all and they just they just saved you know they didn't really have new cars and didn't have fancy holidays and you know it's just yeah it's it always feels like a distant thing doesn't it all this financial planning and when we're going to retire and um but i was recently staying with somebody in ireland when i was over there doing a keynote talk and um the lady i was staying with was 84 and I'm 42. And I literally had this moment of just thinking, gosh, that's nothing. You're exactly double my age.
确实享受了他的生活，他喜欢摆弄他的自行车之类的东西，但他71岁就去世了，那根本不是年纪。一点也不是。他们只是存钱，你知道，他们真的没有新车，也没有豪华假期，你知道，这总是感觉像是一件遥远的事情，不是吗？所有这些财务规划，以及我们什么时候退休。但我最近在爱尔兰时住在一个人的家里，当时我在那里做主题演讲。我住的那位女士84岁，我42岁。我真的有那么一瞬间在想，天哪，那根本不算什么。你正好是我的两倍大。
And it feels like that's no time at all. Before I know it, I will be 84. Yeah. Disappear so quick. And I see that so often. And you can, as much as you're trying i talk with clients about this having a north star in the sky of where you want to get to and where you want to plan and move towards that doesn't have to be rigid that can move that can change and it will
感觉那根本没花多少时间。在我意识到之前，我就会84岁了。是的，消失得太快了。我经常看到这种情况。你可以，尽管你正在尝试……我和客户谈论这个，在天空中有一个北极星，指引你想去的地方，你想规划和迈向的地方。那不必是僵化的，那可以移动，那可以改变，而且它会
because i've seen it and know that most people have seen it over a period of time you make all these best laid plans and then something just throws a spanner in the works and it has to change maybe your partner gets ill. Maybe you're split up. Maybe you get divorced. There's lots of different moving parts in this. But that doesn't mean you disregard it completely and live completely for the now. It's a hard act and a hard balance to get right because society at the moment and how we live is expensive.
因为我见过，而且知道大多数人在一段时间内都见过。你制定了所有这些最好的计划，然后某件事就出了岔子，它必须改变。也许你的伴侣生病了。也许你分手了。也许你离婚了。这里面有很多不同的变动部分。但这并不意味着你完全忽略它，完全只为现在而活。这是一个很难把握的平衡，因为社会目前以及我们的生活方式都很昂贵。
We're in the middle of a cost of living crisis. We've got high interest rates. So if your mortgage is changing, you're probably coming from two percent interest rates to five or six percent interest rates that has a big impact on your monthly um bills like we all know how much more expensive supermarket shopping is how much more expensive petrol is how much more expensive your car insurance is everything is getting more and more expensive that's the impact of inflation and when inflation is running at the rate that it is at the moment which feels a little bit out of control that's the impact of inflation and when inflation is running at the rate that it is at the moment which feels a little bit out of control that has a real impact on the on the
我们正处于生活成本危机的中间。我们有高利率。所以如果你的抵押贷款在变动，你可能正从2%的利率转向5%或6%的利率，这对你的每月账单有很大影响。我们都知道超市购物贵了多少，汽油贵了多少，汽车保险贵了多少，一切都变得越来越贵。这就是通货膨胀的影响。当通货膨胀以目前的速度运行时，感觉有点失控，这就是通货膨胀的影响。当通货膨胀以目前的速度运行时，感觉有点失控，这对
amount that you take you take home every month and sometimes you have to just pull it all in i think i can't think about the long term right now i've planned for that like four or five years ago but i can't think about that right now i I just need to go into survival mode. And I think there's nothing wrong with that because we feel this emotional guilt that we're not going to have the life that we want further down the line, or maybe we're not going to have the round the world trip.
你每月带回家的钱有真正的影响。有时你必须把一切都收紧。我想我现在不能考虑长期了。我在四五年前为那个做过计划，但我现在不能考虑那个。我只需要进入生存模式。我认为这没什么错，因为我们感到一种情感上的内疚，觉得我们将来不会过上我们想要的生活，或者也许我们不会有环球旅行。
But that's no good if you're miserable right now. If you can't afford to live right now and it has an impact on you, your mental health, your wellbeing, your family and all the rest of it, what's the cost and you can't put pounds and pence cost on that stuff yes plan for the future but it's getting that balance right and that's hard and it's hard to do it yourself when you've got emotion involved in it because sometimes somebody else has an extra pair of eyes and ears can see things and have the same conversation you've been having yourself.
但如果你现在很痛苦，那也没用。如果你现在负担不起生活，它对你、你的心理健康、你的幸福、你的家庭等等都有影响，那代价是什么？你无法用英镑和便士来衡量这些东西。是的，为未来做计划，但关键是取得正确的平衡，这很难。当你涉及情感时，自己做这件事很难，因为有时别人作为额外的眼睛和耳朵，可以看到一些东西，并进行你一直在自己进行的同样的对话。
But it sounds differently and it just resonates on a different level to having that conversation with yourself. Thank you. It's really, really useful food for thought. Am I right in thinking that if the worst happens and we don't get to that ripe old age that we'd planned for our retirement, that certainly a private pension can be passed on as an asset. So that then becomes something that you leave for your children. Am I right in that? It is, absolutely. So, I mean, an NHS pension, you can do the same thing,
但它听起来不同，它在不同的层面上产生共鸣，而不是与自己进行那种对话。谢谢。这真是非常有用的思考素材。我没理解错吧，如果最坏的情况发生，我们没有活到我们为退休计划的那个高龄，那么私人养老金肯定可以作为资产传下去。所以那就会变成你留给孩子的东西。我这样理解对吗？是的，绝对是。所以，我的意思是，NHS养老金，你可以做同样的事情，
but the benefits are slightly less. So the NHS pension, we'll start with that one. So that's a defined benefit scheme. So with a degree of predictability, you've got an idea of how much income you're going to have from that pension scheme when you retire. 15, 20 grand a year or whatever it might be. So on your statement, you get every year, it's indexed thing to go to for a period of time. Now, the challenge with those types of scheme is as much as they're great for
但福利稍微少一点。所以NHS养老金，我们从那个开始。所以那是一个固定收益计划。因此，在一定程度上具有可预测性，你对退休时从该养老金计划中获得多少收入有一个概念。每年1.5万或2万英镑，无论金额是多少。所以你在每年收到的对账单上，它会有一段时间的指数化。现在，这些类型计划的挑战在于，尽管它们非常适合
you in the income that you're going to have with your spouse or your partner, whoever else it might be, if something happens to you, those benefits reduce significantly. So else it might be if something happens to you those benefits reduce significantly so typically it would be it would reduce down to 50 so if you've got a income of say 30 000 from your pension then it would reduce down to 15 so your spouse would get 15 if your spouse then passes away nothing then gets left to the kids unless that under the age of 21 in full-time education where they would get i I think it's a 25% pension, but that would only be while they're considered to be financially dependent upon you. Flip that over to the other side and then you've got a private pension. In simple terms, just think of it like a savings account. So it's the £100,000 pension pot that could be passed down to your kids your partner whoever it is that you
如果你和配偶或伴侣或其他任何人共同拥有收入，一旦你发生意外，这些福利会大幅减少。通常情况下，福利会降至50%，所以如果你从养老金中获得3万英镑的收入，它会降至1.5万英镑，也就是说你的配偶只能拿到1.5万英镑。如果你的配偶随后去世，除非孩子未满21岁且在接受全日制教育，否则不会给孩子留下任何东西。如果是这种情况，我想他们能获得25%的养老金，但这仅限于他们被视为在经济上依赖你的期间。换个角度看，如果你有私人养老金，简单来说，把它想象成一个储蓄账户。这笔10万英镑的养老金可以传给你的孩子、伴侣或任何你
decide and that's done really simply when you set the pension up with your financial advisor or even if you haven't used a financial advisor you're completing expression of wish form and that's you saying i want my pension to go to little johnny little jane and my partner mary i don't know where those names came from but but they were the first ones that popped into my head but but they're the ones that that you pass that pension down to. They can do whatever you want with it. Now, the tax benefits would be that if you died before the age of 75, they get that lump sum as they can do whatever they want with.
决定的人。当你与财务顾问建立养老金时，这非常简单；即使你没有使用财务顾问，你也可以填写一份意愿表达书，说明你希望将养老金留给小约翰、小简和我的伴侣玛丽——我不知道这些名字是从哪儿来的，但它们是我脑海中浮现出的第一个名字——但他们就是你将养老金传给的人。他们可以随心所欲地使用这笔钱。现在的税收优惠是，如果你在75岁之前去世，他们可以获得那笔一次性付款，并且可以随心所欲地使用。
They can keep it in a pension or they could take it out. After 75, there's some tax implications. So most of the time, people will just keep that as part of a pension. But I like to talk to clients about it and think of your pension as almost like an extra bit of life insurance so if something does happen to you and you've got a private scheme that could be passed down through the generations doesn't necessarily have to go to your kids because got your grandkids or whoever it is think of that as part of the bigger picture. Thank you. And you mentioned there that it's obviously possible to do investing by yourself without a financial advisor. And for some people perhaps on a lower income,
他们可以将其保留在养老金账户中，也可以取出。75岁之后，会有一些税务影响。所以大多数时候，人们会将其作为养老金的一部分保留。但我喜欢与客户讨论这个问题，把你的养老金看作是一份额外的寿险，如果真的发生了什么事，你有一个可以代代相传的私人计划，它不一定非要给你的孩子，也可以给你的孙辈或任何其他人，把这看作大局的一部分。谢谢。你刚才提到，不找财务顾问自己进行投资显然是可能的。对于一些收入较低的人来说，
that might feel preferable. But I guess the theory is, is that when you go with an IFA, that they try and make you more money than you would do otherwise if you were to do it by yourself is you know because I guess the thing with with financial advisors is that you do pay them a premium um and that can feel quite ouchy and when you do have a lower income it can feel like giving away money that just feels really hard one um how can you kind of balance up the kind of the morals and the ethics of that well that's that's a question and a half um i mean you can do it yourself absolutely what i'd encourage you to think about is have you got the knowledge to be able to do it
这可能感觉更可取。但我猜理论上，当你选择独立财务顾问（IFA）时，他们会试图让你比自己操作赚更多的钱。因为我知道，财务顾问的问题在于你确实需要支付一笔费用，这可能会让人感到心疼，尤其是当你收入较低时，这感觉就像是在送钱，而这些钱赚得非常辛苦。你如何平衡其中的道德和伦理问题？这是一个非常好的问题。我的意思是，你绝对可以自己做，但我鼓励你思考的是：你是否有能力做到这一点？
yourself because if you if you've got the knowledge have you then got the time have you then got the capability and there are three different things to look at there now if you have then yes do it if you haven't then maybe that's the point that you engage a financial advisor and there is a perception that you give having financial advice can be expensive and and i'd probably encourage you to think about it the other way around like what are the costs of you not using a financial advisor because that can be significant there are lots and lots of different studies and you can just put them into Google of financial advice versus not having financial advice. And I think the average difference that makes is a pension of somewhere between an extra two to three thousand pound a year when you retire. Now, if you can use a financial advisor
因为如果你有知识，你是否有时间？你是否有能力？这是三个不同的考量点。如果你都有，那就去做；如果没有，那也许就是你聘请财务顾问的时候了。人们普遍认为获得财务建议很昂贵，但我可能会鼓励你反过来想：不使用财务顾问的成本是多少？因为那可能是巨大的。有很多很多不同的研究，你可以在谷歌上搜索“财务建议与没有财务建议”的对比。我认为这带来的平均差异是退休后每年多出两到三千英镑的养老金。现在，如果你能利用财务顾问
to set that up for you and have that extra two to three thousand pound a year when you retire, when you can't earn anymore, that's a a big difference but that doesn't mean that you can't do that yourself there are so many investment platforms there are lots of self-investment platforms there are a lot of them that will have tutorials and really simple pathways that you can go down to start this thing yourself but my view is that you should be able to have a conversation with a financial advisor. And certainly I do this with clients. You don't need to have me as your financial advisor
为你进行设置，并在退休后每年多出两到三千英镑，当你无法再工作时，这是一个巨大的差异。但这并不意味着你不能自己做。现在有太多的投资平台，有很多自助投资平台，其中很多都有教程和非常简单的路径，你可以开始自己做这件事。但我的观点是，你应该能够与财务顾问进行对话。我当然会和客户这样做。你不需要让我成为你的财务顾问
for the rest of your life. We can have a one-off conversation and we can do that on a basis that works for you. I think the whole world of financial advice is changing. It's changing massively and it will do over the next 10 or 15 years. The vast majority of the industry right now it feels quite transactional so you sit down you go through a process listen to a guy
一辈子。我们可以进行一次性的对话，我们可以以适合你的方式进行。我认为整个财务建议领域正在发生变化。它正在发生巨大的变化，在未来10到15年内将会如此。目前绝大多数行业感觉非常交易化，所以你坐下来，走个流程，听一个家伙
probably in a pinstripe suit with a flash card tell you about how great their business is how much money they look after why you should use them and it feels a bit like a sales pitch and i was part of that world for a long time until i started thinking there was a better way of doing it. Now, I don't operate like that anymore. My view is actually let's figure out what's really, really important to you, why that's really important to you, and then we'll fit the numbers around that. And that's not me trying to convince you for me to be your financial advisor. It's about me planning out what's important to you. And if you want to go and do that yourself, because you've now got the plan from a professional, why not go and do that yourself?
可能穿着细条纹西装，拿着闪卡告诉你他们的业务有多棒，他们管理着多少钱，为什么你应该使用他们，这感觉有点像推销。我在那个世界待了很长时间，直到我开始认为有更好的方法。现在，我不再那样运作了。我的观点实际上是：让我们弄清楚什么对你来说真正重要，为什么它对你很重要，然后我们将数字围绕这一点进行匹配。这不是我在试图说服你让我成为你的财务顾问。这是关于我为你规划什么对你来说是重要的。如果你想自己去执行，因为你现在已经从专业人士那里得到了计划，为什么不自己去做呢？
Because if you can and you're comfortable doing it, then absolutely crack on. And I think the old transaction way was, we'll keep a hold of these relationships for as long as possible. And that world is changing. I think over the next 10 or 15 years, it's going to be incredibly exciting
因为如果你能做到并且对此感到舒适，那就绝对去做吧。我认为旧的交易方式是，我们会尽可能长时间地保持这些关系。而那个世界正在改变。我认为在未来10到15年内，这将是非常令人兴奋的
because more and more people are starting to do this. And there's younger advisors coming in. I think the next evolution is going to be incredibly exciting because more and more people are starting to do this and there's younger advisors coming in i think it's the next evolution is going to be um quite interesting for clients because it is risky it is risky and it's that you know your funds may be at risk that feels oh it feels really scary doesn't it and i don't you know i i definitely don't understand enough to be doing it myself i did have a little bit of a dabble in like an online share trading thing, but I don't know what I'm doing. And it's a small amount, enough amount. It doesn't really matter.
因为越来越多的人开始这样做。而且有更年轻的顾问加入。我认为下一次演变将是非常令人兴奋的，因为越来越多的人开始这样做，而且有更年轻的顾问加入。我认为下一次演变对客户来说会非常有趣，因为它是有风险的，你知道你的资金可能会面临风险，这感觉真的很可怕，不是吗？我肯定没有足够的知识来自己做这件事。我确实尝试过一点点在线股票交易，但我不知道自己在做什么。而且金额很小，没关系。
It doesn't really matter. But I definitely am not good enough to do this by myself for anything more than I have already. I mean, the thing is, you could have a dabble with this stuff, right? You could start off with a relatively small amount and say, well, if I put £100 into one of these accounts, forget about how much it is, but look at the percentage figures on it. So look at the percentage returns. So if you're managing £100, because you need to be able to manage £100
没关系。但我绝对不够好，无法自己做这件事，除了我已经做的那些。我的意思是，你可以尝试一下这些东西，对吧？你可以从相对较小的金额开始，说，如果我往这些账户里存100英镑，别管它是多少，看看上面的百分比数字。所以看看百分比回报。如果你在管理100英镑，因为你需要有能力管理100英镑
and manage £1,000 to manage £100,000 to manage the million, right? You've got to understand the fundamentals of that £100, to manage £1,000, to manage £100,000, to manage the million, right? You've got to understand the fundamentals of that £100. But you could put that into an account and look at the percentages. And if that fund drops 20%, how would you feel if that was £100,000? How would you feel if that was half a million, if that was your life savings? And if that is the kind of thing that worries you, then you need to get a professional involved. If you're okay with those fluctuations, then potentially you could do it yourself. Now, playing around with £100 and actually being at the level where you're managing that yourself and you can have an impact on that return positively and negatively, you've almost got that extra layer of security with a financial advisor in there
并管理1000英镑，才能管理10万英镑，才能管理一百万，对吧？你必须了解那100英镑的基本原理，才能管理1000英镑，才能管理10万英镑，才能管理一百万，对吧？你必须了解那100英镑的基本原理。但你可以把它存入一个账户并观察百分比。如果那只基金下跌了20%，如果是10万英镑，你会感觉如何？如果是50万英镑，如果是你的毕生积蓄，你会感觉如何？如果这是让你担心的事情，那么你需要让专业人士参与进来。如果你能接受这些波动，那么你可能可以自己做。现在，玩弄100英镑，实际上达到你自己管理它的水平，并且你可以对回报产生正面或负面的影响，有了财务顾问，你几乎就有了那层额外的安全保障
because if you make the wrong decision and that drops yourself, how do recover that and that tends to be the thing that happens and i see a lot over the years like people that manage the funds themselves and there's some people out there do great job there's a tendency to over panic so when markets go down there's an over panic of crikey it's dropped 20 what do i do whereas if you take a step back fund managers don't do anything they'll just sit tight because the note will come back you can over trade so you'll buy and sell more more frequently I guess than I would if I was looking after it for you because we're thinking three five year time horizon reset the clock start again and just kind of repeat over a period of time if you're kind of buying and selling stocks and shares to try and make returns on an almost daily or weekly basis that's incredibly
因为如果你做出了错误的决定，资金下跌了，你如何恢复？这往往是多年来我经常看到的情况，那些自己管理基金的人——有些人做得很好——有一种过度恐慌的倾向。所以当市场下跌时，会产生一种“天哪，它跌了20%，我该怎么办”的过度恐慌。而如果你退后一步，基金经理什么都不会做，他们只会按兵不动，因为市场会回升。你可能会过度交易，所以你会比我为你打理时更频繁地买卖，因为我们考虑的是三到五年的时间跨度，重置时钟，重新开始，并在一段时间内重复。如果你为了试图获得回报而几乎每天或每周都在买卖股票，那是极其
risky um there was another one that's just gone so it was the over trading side of things it was the um the panic buying the the tendency to buy funds that you're really comfortable with or name brand names that you that you know which is a good starting point but actually if you think about it all those big companies going to continue that level of growth or do you want like the next amazon the next apple obviously you want the next amazon the next apple but whereas if you're using a fund manager they can potentially spot that because they've got teams of analysts and all that that sit behind that. It's a hard balancing act, but if you can start off relatively small and you're comfortable with it and you can almost multiply that out to the bigger numbers and you still feel comfortable
冒险的。还有一个刚才提到的点，就是过度交易的问题，还有恐慌性买入，以及倾向于购买你非常熟悉的基金或你所知道的品牌名称，这是一个很好的起点，但实际上如果你仔细想想，所有那些大公司都会继续保持那种增长水平吗？还是你想要下一个亚马逊、下一个苹果？显然你想要下一个亚马逊、下一个苹果，但如果你使用基金经理，他们可能能够发现这一点，因为他们背后有分析师团队。这是一个艰难的平衡行为，但如果你能从相对较小的规模开始，并且对此感到舒适，几乎可以将其乘以更大的数字，而你仍然对
with the 20% drop, give it a go. You might just need someone to give you a bit of a help along the way and reach out to financial advisors and say, what are you thinking of this? Can I have a sense check on where I am? Is this going to be able to deliver me a b c and d 100 and there are advisors out there that'll do that for you there are other advisors out there that will say that's your bag you crack on it's you've got to find the right person to work with yeah great advice and you know some advisors are independent and some are not. Is there a right or wrong approach there? How would we even begin to understand why that's a good or bad thing? The thing for me is you need to find an advisor that you trust.
20%的跌幅感到舒适，那就试一试。你可能只需要有人在过程中给你一点帮助，联系财务顾问并说，你觉得这个怎么样？我能对我的现状做一个评估吗？这能实现我的A、B、C和D目标吗？当然可以，而且有顾问会为你做这些。还有其他顾问会说，那是你的事，你自己去处理。你必须找到合适的人来合作。是的，很好的建议。而且你知道，有些顾问是独立的，有些则不是。那里有正确或错误的方法吗？我们怎么开始理解为什么这是一个好或坏的事情？对我来说，你需要找到一个你信任的顾问。
And whether that advisor is on a restricted basis or completely independent, you need to find someone that you're comfortable with. If you want, find another one. And that could mean that there are people out there that I've had conversations with that didn't feel comfortable with me. That's fine. I'm not everybody's cup of tea, and every financial advisor isn't going to be everybody's cup of tea. It's like, get a second opinion. Find someone that you feel confident having those conversations with. And when you do, stick with them. Whether they are restricted, which means they'll work from a certain panel of providers, or they might only work with one internal set of funds, or whether they're independent, which is the whole of market. And I've done both of them. of my career where I wanted more, I guess, options and alternatives to what was available out there
无论该顾问是受限的还是完全独立的，你都需要找到一个让你感到舒适的人。如果愿意，再找一个。这可能意味着有些人我曾与他们交谈过，但他们对我感觉不舒服。没关系。我不是每个人的菜，也不是每个财务顾问都能成为每个人的菜。就像，寻求第二意见。找到一个你觉得可以自信地进行这些对话的人。当你找到时，就坚持下去。无论他们是受限的（这意味着他们将从特定的提供商小组中工作，或者他们可能只与一组内部基金合作），还是独立的（即全市场）。我两者都做过。我的职业生涯中，我想要更多的选择和替代方案，以应对市场上现有的情况
and to be able to fully utilize my 17 years of experience to deliver the best possible outcomes for clients. But that doesn't mean that if you're with a restricted advisor, they're not going to give you the best possible outcome because if they're looking after you properly and they are managing everything properly for you, then why rock the boat? I think a lot of the time it can get all caught up in returns, but if you're with somebody who makes you feel safe, secure, and you're having the right kind of conversations with them, whether they're restricted or independent doesn't really matter.
并能够充分利用我17年的经验，为客户提供尽可能最好的结果。但这并不意味着如果你和受限顾问在一起，他们就不会给你最好的结果，因为如果他们妥善照顾你，并且为你妥善管理一切，那么为什么要折腾呢？我认为很多时候人们会陷入回报的纠结中，但如果你和让你感到安全、有保障的人在一起，并且与他们进行了正确的对话，无论他们是受限的还是独立的，其实并不重要。
If you're just looking from a, I want as many possible options as possible, independent has to be the way to go because you've got the whole of the market available but that doesn't mean it's right for everybody it's about finding the advisor first and then understanding what they can offer yeah absolutely and I think it's like getting any job done in your house you should get at least three quotes shouldn't you should have three meetings with three different advisors and then maybe also try and do a bit of your research yourself to try and get your own kind of sense of what is available and how it compares.
如果你只是从“我想要尽可能多的选择”的角度来看，独立顾问必须是首选，因为你有整个市场可供选择。但这并不意味着它适合每个人，关键是先找到顾问，然后了解他们能提供什么。是的，绝对是这样。我认为这就像在家里完成任何工作一样，你应该至少获得三个报价，不是吗？你应该与三位不同的顾问进行三次会面，然后也许还要尝试自己做一点研究，以尝试获得你自己对现有情况的了解，以及它是如何比较的。
And if it doesn't feel right, don't do it. Even if you have those three meetings, I had someone a couple of years back who I was the seventh advisor that he'd spoken to in a row because he just wasn't sure who he was going to pick, what kind of style he wanted, because we all operate in slightly different ways depending on what our experience is, what our qualifications are. You get a different experience from each advisor, but ultimately he ended up picking me because it was a very different approach. But
如果感觉不对，就不要做。即使你进行了那三次会面，几年前我曾遇到过一个人，我是他连续交谈的第七位顾问，因为他只是不确定他要选谁，他想要什么样的风格，因为我们所有人的运作方式略有不同，取决于我们的经验、我们的资格。你从每位顾问那里得到不同的体验，但最终他选择了我，因为这是一种非常不同的方法。但是
that doesn't mean my approach would work for you. You might want the transactional stuff. You might want to go through the process and just be really hands-off tell me what i need to do and everybody's different um have those conversations and if it doesn't feel right after three then have four maybe have five have six if it doesn't feel right then actually is financial advice right for you do you need to just take a step back for a moment and think well just because everybody's getting financial advice doesn't mean it's the right thing for you right now. I'm a firm believer that everybody should have access
这并不意味着我的方法适合你。你可能想要交易性的东西。你可能想走个流程，然后真的当甩手掌柜，告诉我我需要做什么。每个人都是不同的。进行这些对话，如果三次之后感觉不对，那就四次，也许五次，六次。如果还是感觉不对，那么财务建议真的适合你吗？你需要退后一步思考一下，仅仅因为每个人都在获得财务建议，并不意味着它现在适合你。我坚信每个人都应该有机会
to a financial advisor at some point. It might not be the right point in time for you to have access to them. Then you might just need a bit of a nudge in the right direction from a friend or a relative. Like have those conversations and it's the old stiff British upper lip, isn't it?
在某个时候接触到财务顾问。现在可能不是你接触他们的正确时机。那么你可能只需要朋友或亲戚给你一点正确的指点。进行这些对话，这就是英国人那种老派的“咬紧牙关”的作风，不是吗？
That we don't talk about money because it's rude and crass. Like for me, that's nonsense. Like have the conversations with people that you know, because they'll have made some of the mistakes that you are. You're not going to be asking them exactly what they invest in. Just be like, do you mind just telling me a little bit about what you do with your money?
我们不谈论钱，因为这很粗鲁和庸俗。对我来说，那是胡说八道。和你知道的人进行对话，因为他们会犯下你正在犯的一些错误。你不需要问他们具体投资了什么。只要说：“你不介意告诉我一点你如何处理你的钱吗？”
I don't want to know figures or anything. Like, what do you do? How do you do it? Because you'll get different ideas and everyone's going to have a different opinion and i guess i guess the other caveat i've got to add to that is that's not bob the piss head down the pub who's never got any money because he's always kind of you're always buying him a beer i mean if you look at that logically he's probably not great with money but people that you know are okay with
我不想知道数字或任何东西。就像，你做什么？你怎么做？因为你会得到不同的想法，每个人都会有不同的意见。我想我必须补充的另一个警告是，那不是酒吧里那个总是没钱的酒鬼，因为你总是给他买啤酒。我的意思是，如果你从逻辑上看，他在金钱方面可能不太擅长。但你认识的那些在金钱方面
money are okay financially. Have those conversations. Bob the pisshead down the pub might be richer than anybody because he doesn't spend his own money. You never know. This is it. You never know. I mean, it's unlikely, but it's possible. I love that. And, you know, someone who's in their early 20s, perhaps listening to this, how can they even begin to fathom what they might need and what the cost of living situation is going to be by the time they get to be in their late 60s, early 70s? Probably by the time they get to retire, it might even be 80s.
没问题的人，财务状况良好。进行这些对话。酒吧里的那个酒鬼可能比任何人都富有，因为他不花自己的钱。你永远不知道。就是这样。你永远不知道。我的意思是，这不太可能，但有可能。我喜欢这个。而且，你知道，一个20多岁的人，也许正在听这个，他们怎么能开始理解他们可能需要什么，以及到他们60多岁、70多岁时生活成本会是什么样子？可能到他们退休时，甚至可能是80多岁了。
How can they begin to imagine and work that out, what they might need? It's tough it's really really tough I mean if and if you look at like generationally where we are and how difficult it is for us to get onto the property that like my kids and certainly your kids will find it even harder than we did to get onto that property ladder and are they going to be able to do that without parental support without parental help I don't know and that's that's the hard bit that's the moving part that's the moving part that we just can't predict but what i'd encourage you to do is if you're in that
他们怎么能开始想象并计算出他们可能需要什么？这很难，真的很难。我的意思是，如果你看看我们这一代人所处的位置，以及我们进入房地产市场有多么困难，我的孩子，当然还有你的孩子，会发现比我们更难进入那个房地产阶梯。他们能在没有父母支持、没有父母帮助的情况下做到这一点吗？我不知道，这就是困难的部分，这就是我们无法预测的变数。但我鼓励你做的是，如果你处于那个
position is to just try and and also map out like ultimately dream blue sky scenario what do you want your retirement and your end goal to look like and this is what i talk to clients about and it's that north star in the sky, if everything fell into place and everything happened exactly the way I wanted, which it won't, by the way, what do you want your retirement to look like? Is that going to be like your grandparents? Is it going to be like your parents?
位置，就试着去规划，最终梦想一个蓝图场景，你希望你的退休和最终目标是什么样的？这就是我与客户谈论的内容，这就是天上的北极星。如果一切都到位，一切都按照我想要的方式发生（顺便说一句，这不会发生），你希望你的退休生活是什么样的？它会像你祖父母那样吗？会像你父母那样吗？
Is it going to be like your Uncle Bob? Whoever it is, try and paint that picture a little bit. And if you can paint that picture, then you could almost reverse engineer that right the way back to where you are now. And it might be that you can't do that. And it might be that all you can paint that picture, then you could almost reverse engineer that right the way back to where you are now. And it might be that you can't do that. And it might be that all you can think about is the next five years. And that next five years might be, I want to get on the property ladder.
会像你鲍勃叔叔那样吗？无论那是谁，试着描绘一下那幅图景。如果你能描绘出那幅图景，那么你几乎可以把它反向工程回你现在所处的位置。可能你做不到。可能你所能做的就是描绘那幅图景，然后几乎可以把它反向工程回你现在所处的位置。可能你做不到。可能你所能想到的只是接下来的五年。而接下来的五年可能是：我想进入房地产市场。
I want to make sure I've got some savings behind me in case the shit hits the fan, washing machine breaks down or whatever it might be. I want to be able to afford to put the kids into nursery because I plan to go back to school just figure that out and talk that through if you've got a partner to do that with amazing if you've got um friends you can have that conversation with great because certainly what i found is having those things in your head is very different to writing them down on a sheet of paper or very different to verbalizing them because they sound very differently and resonate on a different level and if it is just a five-year plan of i want to get on the property ladder or i want to move out of the family home or whatever it might be then try and figure out what that looks like you don't have to do it all at once like if we all did it all at once and we all kind
我想确保我有积蓄，以防万一发生什么糟糕的事情，洗衣机坏了或者其他什么事情。我想有能力负担得起把孩子送到托儿所，因为我计划重返学校。只要弄清楚这一点并讨论一下。如果你有一个可以一起做这件事的伴侣，太棒了；如果你有可以进行这种对话的朋友，很好。因为我确实发现，把这些事情放在脑子里和把它们写在纸上或把它们说出来是非常不同的，因为它们听起来非常不同，并在不同的层面上产生共鸣。如果这只是一个五年的计划，比如我想进入房地产市场，或者我想搬出家门，或者其他什么，那就试着弄清楚那是什么样子的。你不必一次性完成所有事情。如果我们都一次性完成，我们都
of in our 20s knew exactly what we were going to do for the rest of our lives, we'd all be retired at 55. You'd all be retired at 50 and you'd all have a great old life and the poverty wouldn't exist and all these other kind of horrible things that are out there because we'd all have our, I nearly swore again, we'd all have everything together and know exactly the direction we're going. And that's impossible. But sometimes it's just figure out maybe the five-year plan and then the next step then the one after that and the one after that and the one after that and that's what i tell clients we'll figure out what the long-term really important stuff is and why that's important to you we'll try and reverse engineer that and if we can't we'll just
在20多岁时就知道我们余生要做什么，我们都会在55岁退休。你们都会在50岁退休，你们都会过上美好的生活，贫困就不会存在，所有那些外面存在的其他可怕的事情也不会存在，因为我们都会把一切都准备好，确切地知道我们要去的方向。那是不可能的。但有时只是弄清楚也许是五年计划，然后是下一步，然后是再下一步，再下一步，再下一步。这就是我告诉客户的，我们会弄清楚长期真正重要的事情是什么，以及为什么这对你很重要。我们会尝试反向工程，如果我们做不到，我们就会
figure out what we're going to do tomorrow and then and we're going to do next month, next six months, next year. And then all of a sudden, you're two, three years in, and you've got that plan that starts to kind of fall into place. Yeah, it's tricky, isn't it? This is, I guess, where dream boards and vision boards and Pinterest come in in that you can dare to imagine what you might want your life to look like. And that's not suggesting, you know, don't be disloyal to the life we're living now. I think speaking as a psychologist, we can be quite good at making the best of the situation we're in. And change can be tricky as well. But it's knowing that you do deserve to have a life that's enjoyable that feels comfortable that um you know it's got
弄清楚我们明天要做什么，然后是下个月，接下来的六个月，明年。然后突然之间，你已经进行了两三年，你就有了一个开始落实的计划。是的，这很棘手，不是吗？我想这就是梦想板、愿景板和Pinterest发挥作用的地方，你可以敢于想象你希望你的生活是什么样的。这并不是建议，你知道，不要对我们现在过的生活不忠诚。我认为作为一名心理学家，我们非常擅长充分利用我们所处的环境。改变也可能很棘手。但要知道，你确实值得拥有一个令人愉快、感觉舒适的生活，而且，你知道，它有
good stuff in it and you're allowed you know I think and we spoke briefly last time about money trauma as well didn't we you know the messages we get given from others around us as we grow up about how how it is if you spend money you know you're really decadent or you know too carefree or um you know I think I said that my mum always would be an egg sandwich girl because they're the cheapest in the shop, you know, and anything more than that is just decadent, you know. But it's allowing yourself to free yourself from the shackles of what you've been told
好东西在里面，而且你是被允许的。你知道，我想我们上次简短地谈到了金钱创伤，不是吗？你知道我们成长过程中从周围人那里得到的关于金钱的信息，如果你花钱，你知道，你真的很颓废，或者你知道太无忧无虑，或者，你知道，我想我说过我妈妈总是会买鸡蛋三明治，因为它们是店里最便宜的，你知道，除此之外的任何东西都只是颓废，你知道。但这是允许自己从被告知的枷锁中解放出来
and actually doing what makes you happy, which can be liberating. A hundred percent. And it's that balance piece again and it's a it's a word that i use all of the time it's that balance of here and now in the future but one of the things that i kind of hear a lot from clients in the 50s and clients in the 40s i wish i'd started sooner i wish i'd taken this stuff a little bit more seriously in my 20s i'm exactly the same been there done it struggled young kids, couldn't make ends meet at the end of the month, kind of stuff on
并真正做让你快乐的事情，这可能是解放性的。百分之百。这又是平衡的问题，这是一个我一直使用的词，它是此时此地与未来的平衡。但我从50多岁和40多岁的客户那里听到很多的一件事是：我希望我早点开始。我希望我在20多岁时更认真地对待这些事情。我完全一样，经历过，挣扎过，有年幼的孩子，月底入不敷出，那种信用卡上的东西，或者经历过。我已经犯了所有可能犯的财务错误。但总的来说，我希望我在20多岁时有更多的金融素养，并且知道这些东西。而且我认为我们有一代人正在职场中成长，当然还有我们的孩子，所有这些信息都是可用的。这是一个好的、积极的事情，因为它可能是信息过载，你只是觉得你无法行动
credit cards, or been there and done it. I've kind of made every possible financial mistake you could have possibly made. But overall, I wish I'd been more financially literate when I was in my 20s and knew about this stuff. And I think we've got a generation of people kind of growing up through the workplace and certainly our kids where all of this information is available. And that's a good and a positive thing because it could be information overload and you just feel like you can't move
因为外面有太多的信息。老实说，你在社交媒体上看到的很多东西有时可能是垃圾。我认为关键是要有选择性地对待你认为相关的信息，并朝着这些目标努力，帮助你实现这些目标。比如要成功，你不需要在车道上停五辆兰博基尼，住在洛杉矶的一栋2500万美元的房子里，你知道，定义你现在的成功定义是什么。那可能只是月底还有10英镑可以存起来，并想：“我已经开始了我的财务之旅。我已经开始了我的储蓄。”对我来说，这非常巨大。这比那个每月能存2万英镑的人更有价值，因为你已经开始了。你已经开始了那段旅程，这应该受到赞扬和称赞，因为它极其重要，因为那是第一步，在那之后是第二步，在那之后是第三步，然后它就变成了
because there's so much information out there. And let's be honest, a lot of the stuff that you see on social media can be rubbish at times. I think it's about being selective about the information that you think would be relevant and work towards and help you along those goals. Like to be successful, you don't need to have five Lamborghinis parked in your drive and live in a
一段时间后的例行公事。就像那句短语，无论你什么时候买一辆新车，如果你买了一辆新的大众高尔夫，你会到处看到它们，每个人都有大众高尔夫。他们并没有一辆新的大众高尔夫，你只是在开始对财务更加关注时，对它更加敏感了。然后突然之间，当你只能负担得起每月10英镑时，下个月突然之间你可能可以负担20英镑，因为你对五年后的目标以及10或20英镑一个月能产生什么影响有了更多的了解。然后突然之间是30、40、50，加薪了，也许你有一些额外的钱进来。也许你减少了开支。
$25 million house in LA, you know, define what your definition of success is right now. And that might just be getting to the end of the month and having £10 a month to be able to put aside and think I've started my financial journey. I've started my savings. That to me is massive. That's much more valuable than the guy who can put 20 grand a month away because you've got started. You've started that journey and that should be applauded and should be lauded because it's incredibly important because that's the first step and after that comes a second step after that comes the third one and then it just becomes
它就开始产生一些动力。如果你能抓住这一点，它会为你的一生打下基础，而不是到了40多岁和50多岁时说：“我希望我早点开始。”我确实希望我早点开始。我确实希望。我们一直听到这个。所以，是的，现在正在听的20多岁的人，现在就开始，现在就开始。嗯，我想我感到，我感到很傻，伊恩。我感到很傻，因为我当时甚至没有男朋友或长期伴侣。我感觉就像，哦，只是小小的我，就像，哦
routine over a period of time and it's the phrase of like whenever you get a new car if you buy a new vw golf you'll see them everywhere everybody's got a vw golf they haven't got a new vw golf you're just more aware of it when you start being more aware with your finances then all of a sudden when you could just afford to do 10 pound a month then next month all of a sudden you can probably do 20 because you're a little bit more aware of what the goal is in the five years and what impact a 10 or a 20 pound a month can make and then all of a sudden it's 30 40 50 get a pay rise maybe you get some extra money coming in. Maybe you reduce your costs.
这有点尴尬，有点令人畏缩，不是吗？所有这些养老金和投资。但这并不傻，是吗？不是。一点也不。就像我刚才说的，多年来，那些在40多岁和50多岁时拥有财务安全的人，就是那些现在开始的人。是那些在20多岁时开始，并开始认真对待这些事情的人
And it just starts to gather some traction. If you can grasp that, it sets you up for life rather than getting to 40s and 50s and saying, I wish I'd started sooner. And I do wish I'd started sooner. I do. We hear that all the time. So, yeah, the people listening now that are in their early 20s start now start now um i think it's that i felt i felt silly ian i felt silly because i didn't even have a boyfriend a long-term partner at that time i felt like oh just little old me like oh
你必须从10英镑和25英镑或其他什么地方开始。这令人畏缩，但这并不傻。你可能认为这很无聊，但我告诉你什么不无聊：在55岁时退休，而其他人还在工作。当所有那些因为你在20多岁时把钱存入养老金而嘲笑你的人，在50多岁和60多岁时还在辛苦工作，而你一年中有六个月坐在海滩上，那并不无聊，这就是现实。对，我有，我有，我多年来有过客户，他们走到了另一个极端。我会举一个例子，有一个家伙，我很久以前给他提供过抵押贷款建议
it's a bit embarrassing bit cringe isn it? All this pension and investing. It's not silly though, is it? It's not. Not at all. Like that's the stuff that over the years, like I said earlier, the people that have got that financial security in the 40s and 50s are the ones that start now. It's the ones that started in the 20s and start taking this stuff
前，他25岁，全职水管工，经营自己的生意，和爸爸住在一起，从不花钱，25岁时银行里有25万英镑。我说，哇，那太不可思议了。你打算用它做什么？他说，嗯，我想把它存到40万，然后我想买房子。太好了。你为什么要买房子？因为我为我的家人提供了保障。太棒了。你一周工作几天？一周七天。你有休息时间吗？不，从不去度假。我每天工作12小时。太好了。所以你将拥有这个价值40万英镑的大房子，四间卧室以及所有其他东西，只是为你自己。他说，嗯，你是什么意思？我说，嗯，如果你那样做，你打算怎么认识某人？然后他突然恍然大悟。
a little bit seriously. And you've got to start somewhere with like the 10 and the 25 quid or whatever it is. It's cringe it's not silly you might think it's boring but i tell you what's not boring retiring at 55 when everyone else is out working like when all those people that are kind of taking the mick out of you because you put your money at your pension when you're in your 20s and they're still slogging away in the 50s and 60s and you're kind of sat on a beach for six months of the year that's not boring and that's the reality of it right i've got i've got i've had clients over the years and who've taken to the other extreme and i'll use one example there was a guy that i gave mortgage advice to a long
他就像，是的，你是对的。因为他太专注于赚钱了，他只是忘记了生活中其他的一切。所以这是极端的另一面。而在中间的某个地方是正确的平衡。这并不意味着你必须遵循那条路线，如果你想的话，没问题。但这就是此时此地，只是带着一只眼睛关注你想要达到的未来。是的，是的，我知道当你为养老金储蓄时，当它从你的账户中扣除
time ago and he's he's 25 full-time plumber ran his own business lived at home with his dad never spent any money had 250 grand in the bank at 25. And I'm like, wow, that's incredible. What are you going to do with that? He said, well, I want to get it at 400, then I want to buy a house. Great. What do you want to buy a house for? Because I've got security for my family. Amazing. How many days a week do you work? Seven days a week. Do you have any time off? No, never go on holiday. And I work 12 hour days. Great. So you're going to have this big 400 grand house, four bedrooms and all the rest of it just for you. And he's like, well, what do you mean? I said, well, how are you going to meet somebody if you do that? And the penny just dropped all of a sudden.
或从你的工资中扣除时，它是税前扣除的，不是吗？但当它再次回到你手中时，如果你赚的钱超过了应纳税门槛，它确实会被征税，对吗？确实是的。好的，你学得很好，做得好。所以，是的，你绝对会。但我认为区别在于，你有权控制你如何获取该收入。所以是的，你存入的钱，你将节省税款，但你在后端被征税。但你现在作为基本税率纳税人节省的税款，你存入养老金，它会被额外增加20%，所以你获得了税收减免。高税率，那是40%。如果你从你的企业和你的公司税率中这样做，
He was like, yeah, you're right. Because he's been so focused on earning that money, he's just forgotten about everything else in his life. So that's the far extreme of it. And somewhere in the middle is the right balance. It doesn't mean you kind of follow that route if you want to, fine. But it's that here and now but just getting started with one eye just in the future of where you want to get to yeah yeah and i know that when you're saving for a pension when it gets taken out
取决于你的营业额，你的企业现在可以为你的养老金做出贡献。快进到30、40年后，你有了这笔巨大的养老金，你想开始从中取钱。如果你有其他资产，也许是房产、储蓄、投资或其他什么，你可以在一定程度上控制你如何获取该收入。你可能决定从你的投资中获取收入，如果它们是ISA，它们可能是免税的，所以你可以从那个账户中提取高达高税率的金额。你在那方面有更多的灵活性。是的，你知道，你在某个时候必须为此支付一些税款，但正如我在开始时所说，如果你不花它，它可以传给你的孩子，它可以传给你的伴侣，还有各种其他方式。
of your account or taken out of your wages it gets taken off pre-tax doesn't it but when it comes back to you again it does then get taxed if you're earning over the taxable threshold is that right it does yeah all right you're learning well done so so you do absolutely so but i suppose the difference is you've got control over how you take that income. So yes, the money that you go in, you're going to save tax, but you're paid on the back end. But that money that you're saving tax now is a basic rate taxpayer. You put your pension contribution in, it will get rounded up by an additional 20% so you get tax relief. Higher rate tax, that's 40%. If you do that out your business and your corporation tax rate,
如果你想变得非常技术性，有时你可以利用养老金进行借贷来做事情，如果你有自己的企业。税收是你无法真正避免的事情之一。这就是我刚才说的老话，你无法避免的一件事是债务和税收。它发生在我们所有人身上，但你可以比你受雇或必须建立企业时更好地控制你在退休时支付的税收水平。此外，你还可以获得25%的免税额，你可以以一次性付款的方式从你的养老金中取出。这可能足以让你维持四五年，或者偿还抵押贷款，或者进行
depending on what your turnover is, your business can contribute to your pension now fast forward to 30 40 years down the line you've got this great big pension pot that you want to start taking some money from if you've got other assets maybe property savings investments or whatever it is you can control to a certain extent how you take that income um you might decide that you take an income out of your investments and they might be tax-free if you've got them as isis so you can take up to higher rate tax out of that pot you've got a lot more flexibility on that yes you know what you've got to pay some tax on it at some point potentially but as i said at the start that if you don't spend it that could go to your kids, that could go to your partner, there could be various other ways.
环球旅行。养老金在存入时非常节税。如果你管理得当，它们在取出时也可以同样节税。啊，所以这就是当你听到人们退休时，他们说，哦，我有一笔一次性付款和我的养老金。这就是你的意思。是的，绝对是。就是这样。
If you want to get really technical, sometimes you can borrow against the pension to do things, if you've got your own business. Tax is one of those things that you can't really avoid. It's that old thing I just said, the one thing that you can't avoid is debt and taxes. It happens to all of us, but you can have control over the level of tax you pay in your retirement much more than you can when you're employed or when you're necessarily building a business plus you also get 25 tax free you can take out your pension as a lump sum anyway that might be enough to keep you taking over for four or five years or to pay the mortgage off or have
而且它能产生很大的差异。很多人只是在退休时梦游，直到你到了后端才真正审查这些东西。天哪，我该怎么办？好吧，如果你等到退休前三周才看这些东西，那就太晚了。你需要持续地在临近退休时查看这些，以了解你是否在轨道上，偏离轨道，你能做什么。你需要被踢屁股以投入更多的钱吗？你有
the route around the world trip pensions are very tax efficient when you go in. They can be just as tax efficient on the way out if you manage them properly. Aha, so that's when you hear people retiring and they say, oh, I've got a lump sum and my pension. That's like, that's what you mean. Yeah, absolutely. That's it.
环球旅行的养老金在存入时非常节税。如果你管理得当，在取出时也可以同样节税。啊，所以这就是当你听到人们退休时说，哦，我有一笔养老金总额。这就是你的意思。是的，绝对是这样。就是这样。
And it can make a big difference. And a lot of people just kind of almost sleepwalk into retirement without really reviewing this stuff until you get to the back end of it. Oh my God, what am I going to do? Well, if you wait until three weeks before you retire to look at this stuff, it's too late. You need to be looking at this consistently on the run up there to know whether you're on track, off track, what you can do. Do you need to kick up the backside to put more money in? Have you
这可能会带来很大的不同。很多人几乎是在不知不觉中进入退休状态，直到最后阶段才真正审视这些问题。天哪，我该怎么办？好吧，如果你等到退休前三周才去考虑这些事情，那就太晚了。你需要在此之前的过程中持续关注，以了解你是否在正轨上，是否偏离了轨道，以及你能做些什么。你是否需要加把劲多存点钱？你是否
got enough? Are there other things that you could be doing? I think I'm a big believer in having as many different things pushing in that direction as possible. It's not just your pension. That could be your business. That could be your property. That could be your savings, your investments. That could be other things that you're involved in. The more you've got pushing that way, the more security you've got that you're going to hit that end goal at the back end. Yeah, and I guess I'm part of the kind of spread your risk kind of philosophy. So because I'm self-employed, I only pay my tax twice a year. and i don't trust myself not to spend it and so i save that by putting that up into premium bonds which is kind of guaranteed isn't it it's um you know you can do up to 50 grand a year and that's that money's safe as housing because that's um that's with the government
足够了吗？还有其他你可以做的事情吗？我非常相信尽可能多地从不同方向推动目标。这不仅仅是你的养老金。它可以是你的生意。可以是你的房产。可以是你的储蓄、你的投资。也可以是你参与的其他事情。你推动的方向越多，你最终实现目标的保障就越多。是的，我想我是那种分散风险哲学的一部分。因为我是自雇人士，我一年只交两次税。我不信任自己不会花掉这些钱，所以我把钱存入高级债券（Premium Bonds），这算是一种保证，对吧？你知道，你一年最多可以存5万英镑，这笔钱像房子一样安全，因为这是由政府担保的。
um but actually you can earn money on that you win money but then you can earn money on the money that's invested again so that becomes compound in itself I think is that right of course yeah absolutely and it makes a big difference long term plus the tax relief and everything else that comes with it it's huge yeah and my dad um when he passed away he left my boys um a small amount of money and I decided to put that into premium bonds for them. And the other day, my youngest came home and on the sofa was a letter from them saying he'd won £150. And like, you know, it's amazing, isn't it? Because actually there's not a huge amount in there, but that's what he'd won.
嗯，但实际上你可以在那上面赚钱，你赢了钱，然后你又可以在投资的钱上赚钱，所以这本身就变成了复利，我想是对的吧？当然，绝对是这样，从长远来看，这会有很大的不同，再加上税收减免和其他随之而来的好处，这非常巨大。是的，我爸爸去世时，他给我的孩子们留了一小笔钱，我决定为他们存入高级债券。前几天，我最小的孩子回家时，沙发上有一封信，说他赢了150英镑。就像，你知道，这很神奇，对吧？因为实际上里面没有多少钱，但这就是他赢的钱。
And, you know, he's like, oh, amazing. What can I buy with that? And I'm like, well, nothing. We're going to leave it in there and see what happens for your future. But already the boys are like, oh, that means I've got more than you now because I've won. You know, and it's, you know, it's yeah, it's safe to have conversations with our children about money, isn't it as well? It's so important. I mean, you know better than anybody else like at what age kids cognitive behavior is set by and what an influence we have on our kids behaviors and how they manage their
而且，你知道，他就像，哦，太棒了。我可以用它买什么？我说，嗯，什么都不能买。我们要把它留在那里，看看你的未来会怎样。但孩子们已经说，哦，那意味着我现在比你有钱了，因为我赢了。你知道，这，你知道，是的，和我们的孩子谈论金钱是安全的，对吧？这太重要了。我的意思是，你比任何人都更清楚孩子在什么年龄认知行为就定型了，以及我们对孩子行为的影响，以及他们如何管理他们的
behavior but importantly how they manage their money because they learn from us all of the time and us modeling certain kinds of behavior has such a positive impact on the kids and it's exactly the same the other way around like if we are spending money willy-nilly and quite freely on all kinds of stuff then your kids are going to grow up in that environment of thinking that that's acceptable if you're in mountains of debt then they're probably going to follow the same route it's very difficult for them to break out of it so as much as managing your own money is important just remember you're setting examples for your kids and how they manage theirs as well getting them involved in those conversations as early as possible makes such a difference and it's it doesn't necessarily have to start with things like pocket money it could be
行为，但重要的是他们如何管理他们的金钱，因为他们一直在向我们学习，我们塑造某些行为对孩子有如此积极的影响，反之亦然。如果我们随意地花钱，在各种东西上挥霍，那么你的孩子就会在那种认为这是可以接受的环境中长大。如果你负债累累，那么他们很可能会走同样的路线，他们很难摆脱这种困境。所以，管理好自己的钱很重要，但要记住，你正在为你的孩子树立榜样，以及他们如何管理自己的钱。尽早让他们参与这些对话会产生很大的不同，而且这不一定非要从零花钱之类的事情开始，它可以是
you just talk to them about managing the money and managing a savings account or how you pay your bills every month or what a mortgage is what a what rent is what council tax having those conversations and keeping them open i think the education system's got a long way to go to kind of have those those conversations as well there are some incredible things happening in the background there are lots of um startup foundations i'm involved with one of them that will go into schools and talk to them about financial education what a mortgage is what a savings account is what abcd is and just really distilled out the simple forms because again as parents not everybody knows this stuff like not everybody knows what a what a mortgage is how that works and what an
你只是和他们谈论管理金钱和管理储蓄账户，或者你每个月如何支付账单，或者什么是抵押贷款，什么是租金，什么是市政税。进行这些对话并保持开放，我认为教育系统在进行这些对话方面还有很长的路要走。后台正在发生一些令人难以置信的事情，有很多初创基金会，我参与了其中一个，他们会进入学校，和他们谈论金融教育，什么是抵押贷款，什么是储蓄账户，什么是ABCD，并真正提炼出简单的形式，因为同样作为父母，并不是每个人都知道这些东西，不是每个人都知道什么是抵押贷款，它是如何运作的，以及什么是
investment is and what a stock or a share is but by having those conversations we're just equipping our children a lot better and and they're also going to be able to cut through the noise and see through the bs because there's a lot of it out there in social media and they're growing up in a generation of where as i said earlier unless you're unless you're jake paul and driving a lamborghini then that's not that's not classed as success like that's not success that's just i mean i'm sure the guys worked incredibly hard to get there but that doesn't mean if you don't hit that level that you failed at all yeah I hear you my kids both want to be either premiership footballers or youtubers and have seven cars in the garage
投资，什么是股票或份额，但通过进行这些对话，我们只是让我们的孩子装备得更好，他们也将能够穿透噪音，看穿胡说八道，因为社交媒体上有很多这样的东西。他们成长在这样一个时代，正如我之前所说，除非你是杰克·保罗（Jake Paul）并开着兰博基尼，否则那不被视为成功。那不是成功，那只是，我的意思是，我相信这些人为了达到那个目标付出了难以置信的努力，但这并不意味着如果你没有达到那个水平，你就失败了。是的，我听到了，我的孩子们都想成为英超足球运动员或YouTuber，并在车库里有七辆车
and it's like oh baby boys like your mummy's got a 10 year year old persia and she's actually a really nice person and works really hard and you know that's still really incredibly important um but it's almost like go big or go home like they're not they can't they can't see anything else as being viable i had the same with my two like they both want to be professional footballers both played football to a high enough standard but once they started getting to a certain standard and they realized the level of commitment involved neither of them wanted to do that anymore it just kind of felt like it was going to overtake their life to get there and ultimately that's that's a great point because if you want to get to that youtube level of stardom you want to get
就像，哦，宝贝们，你们妈妈有一辆10年的标致，她其实是一个非常好的人，工作非常努力，你知道，这仍然非常非常重要。但这几乎就像是“要么做大，要么回家”——他们看不到其他任何可行的东西。我的两个孩子也一样，他们都想成为职业足球运动员，都踢到了足够高的水平，但一旦他们开始达到某个标准，意识到所涉及的承诺水平，他们都不想再那样做了。这感觉就像为了达到目标，生活会被接管，归根结底，这是一个很好的观点，因为如果你想达到那种YouTube明星的水平，你想达到
to that professional sports level of stardom or ceo of like a worldwide company it's got to take over your life it's got to be a big life commitment and i kind of had that realization a while back that i could have all that stuff if i really wanted it but do it do i really want it and it's that old adage of do you want to be a millionaire do you want to spend a million pounds and i think the vast majority of people would like to spend a million pounds but they don't necessarily want to be a millionaire because to get to a millionaire is a lot of graft work blood sweat and tears to get there and I think that's missing but I think as kids kind of grow older they start to realize that level of commitment it takes to get to that point and I think the people
那种职业体育明星的水平，或者像全球性公司的首席执行官，它必须接管你的生活，它必须是一个巨大的生活承诺。我前段时间意识到，如果我真的想要，我可以拥有所有这些东西，但我真的想要吗？这就是那句老话：你想成为百万富翁，还是想花一百万英镑？我认为绝大多数人想花一百万英镑，但他们不一定想成为百万富翁，因为要成为百万富翁需要大量的苦干、血汗和泪水。我认为这一点被忽略了，但我认为随着孩子们长大，他们开始意识到达到那一点所需的承诺水平，我认为
listening to this podcast will absolutely resonate with what you've said about the hard graft because what you may not realize is that it's really, really, really hard to become a professionally qualified psychologist as well. It's so competitive that lots of people do, like you say, just give up or decide that, you know, they're going to do something different instead, because it's, you know, there's so much rejection, there's so much, much you know uncertainty that the people you then do see as qualified psychologists have absolutely you know put in that graft and the perseverance and taken the knockbacks and the setbacks and the the kind of not knowing whether
听这个播客的人绝对会与你所说的关于艰苦工作产生共鸣，因为你可能没有意识到，成为一名专业合格的心理学家也非常、非常、非常困难。竞争非常激烈，以至于很多人，正如你所说，只是放弃或决定做其他事情，因为，你知道，有太多的拒绝，有太多的不确定性，所以你看到的那些合格的心理学家绝对是付出了努力、毅力，并承受了挫折和打击，以及那种不知道是否
the prize will ever come um so yeah it's i think people will absolutely resonate with what you've said but it also hopefully means they're going to go the hard graft to really make their savings become their wealth, you know, and make that work for themselves too. And it takes some of the pressure off by doing that. Like, I get the hard graft. You've got to put those hard yards in earlier on in your career. But if you can get the finances and get on top of those, it means that further down the line,
奖赏终会到来。所以是的，我认为人们绝对会与你所说的话产生共鸣，但也希望这意味着他们会去努力工作，真正让他们的储蓄变成他们的财富，你知道，并让这些钱为他们自己工作。这样做可以减轻一些压力。就像，我明白艰苦工作。你必须在职业生涯的早期付出那些艰苦的努力。但如果你能搞定财务并掌握它们，这意味着在未来，
you don't have to put that graft in anymore because you've got that security blanket of knowing I'm financially secure, I'm okay. And that's an incredible place to be in. And the difference you can see in people when they get to that point is, well, it's life-changing. Not everyone will get there, though. And I also understand that. I don't mean that everybody has to get there because everybody's got their own different version of freedom and what their life wants to look like it's not for me to dictate which which way is right and which way is wrong but certainly in the world that i operate in that financial
你不再需要那样辛苦工作了，因为你有了那种安全感，知道我在经济上是安全的，我很好。这是一个令人难以置信的境地。当你看到人们达到那一点时，那种差异是改变生活的。不过，并不是每个人都能达到那里。我也明白这一点。我并不是说每个人都必须达到那里，因为每个人都有自己对自由的不同定义，以及他们想要的生活是什么样子的。我不应该去规定哪种方式是对的，哪种方式是错的，但肯定在我所处的领域，那种财务
security piece is is really important it makes such a difference it really is and you before we hit record you and i were talking about strategy in business but the same is true in employed life as well you know you're allowed to have a strategy for your life and that can change over time it can change as regularly as you need but it just make makes us a bit less aimless is the hope isn't it absolutely and over the years i'm sure we've both worked with people that have had one job for one company for the rest for all of their lives and like that wasn't for me but that was perfect for them that was perfect for them and they've got to the end of their life end of their kind of working life and thought great i've spent 30 years with one company and that's been enough for me and happy days i'm happy like that's why life's so great because there are so many different options
安全感是非常重要的，它确实带来了很大的不同。确实如此。在你我开始录音之前，我们谈到了商业策略，但在受雇生活中也是如此。你知道，你可以为你的生活制定策略，而且它可以随着时间的推移而改变，它可以根据需要经常改变，但希望这能让我们少一点漫无目的，对吧？绝对是这样。多年来，我相信我们都曾与那些一生只为一家公司工作的人共事过，这对我来说不适合，但对他们来说是完美的。他们走到了生命的尽头，结束了工作生涯，心想：太棒了，我在一家公司工作了30年，这对我来说已经足够了。快乐的日子，我很高兴。这就是为什么生活如此美好，因为有这么多不同的选择
about what you can do and what that means for you in terms of your happiness your well-being your financial status your financial security all of those things there's so many moving parts and so many different avenues you can take and you can always reinvent the wheel and kind of go down a different route and try something else yeah honestly Ian I think we will have to invite you back for another another money clinic because there's just so many questions and so many it's just you make everything so accessible and so easy to understand so thank you for your time how can people learn more about you and your work because they will want to i know okay really simple i am
关于你能做什么，以及这对你的幸福、健康、财务状况、财务安全意味着什么，所有这些事情都有太多的活动部件和太多的不同途径。你可以随时重塑自我，走一条不同的路线，尝试其他事情。是的，老实说，伊恩，我想我们必须邀请你回来参加另一个理财诊所，因为有太多的问题，你让一切都变得如此容易接近和理解，所以谢谢你的时间。人们如何能更多地了解你和你的工作？因为他们会想了解的，我知道。好的，非常简单，我
on linkedin so if you just search for ian dempsey on linkedin i haven't got a website yet that's as we're talking about strategy and business, that's job number 345 on the list. That's going to come eventually, but I'm on LinkedIn. I share lots of information about budgeting, finances, money. I'm a big believer in education. All the stuff I've talked about today, most of that was probably kind of in posts from LinkedIn anyway.
在LinkedIn上，所以如果你在LinkedIn上搜索Ian Dempsey，我还没有网站，正如我们谈论策略和商业时所说，那是清单上的第345项工作。最终会有的，但我现在在LinkedIn上。我分享了很多关于预算、财务、金钱的信息。我非常相信教育。我今天谈到的所有内容，大部分可能已经在LinkedIn的帖子中了。
Follow me along. Ask me any questions that you've got. I'll share as much information as I can to kind of demystify the smoke and mirrors of finances. Lovely. And I think what I might do, Ian, is I might schedule this for January
关注我。问我你有的任何问题。我会分享我能分享的所有信息，以揭开财务的神秘面纱。太好了。我想我可能会做的是，伊恩，我可能会把它安排在一月份
because that feels like kind of an optimistic time. What's your top tip for making 2024 your wealthiest, most productive year yet for your money? We could do a whole episode on that. I think it's been really, try and be really clear about what you want.
因为那感觉是一个乐观的时间。你让2024年成为你最富有、最高产的一年的顶级建议是什么？我们可以为此做一整集。我认为这真的很重要，试着非常清楚你想要什么。
And there's some questions that I always ask my clients, like, what do you want out of this process? So I'm sat down with a client and they're talking about financial advice on money. What do you want out of the process? So if you're going to get on top of your finances, like why? Why is that important to you? What do you want to achieve by doing it? Why is that important to you? And how are you going to feel when you get there? And I think if you can answer those questions honestly and openly, and that doesn't necessarily mean the first answer is
我总是问我的客户一些问题，比如，你从这个过程中想要什么？所以我坐在客户面前，他们谈论关于金钱的财务建议。你从这个过程中想要什么？所以如果你要掌握你的财务，为什么？为什么这对你很重要？你想通过这样做实现什么？为什么这对你很重要？当你达到目标时，你会有什么感觉？我认为如果你能诚实、公开地回答这些问题，这并不一定意味着第一个答案
going to be the right one because it might not be be but if you can write it down on a sheet of paper and think about maybe when you're walking the dog out on a run and all of a sudden it hits you between the eyes that's the right answer and that's what i talk to clients about if you can get really clear on those four five things the next step after that is fairly logical you can just kind of drop things into place but in terms of fixing your finances for 2024 complete a budget plan and know what you've The next step after that is fairly logical. You can just kind of drop things into place. But in terms of fixing your finances for 2024, complete a budget plan. Know what you've got coming in, going out. Put your money to work.
就是正确的，因为它可能不是。但如果你能把它写在一张纸上，想想也许当你遛狗、跑步时，突然间它击中了你的要害，那就是正确的答案，这就是我和客户谈论的内容。如果你能真正弄清楚那四五件事，接下来的步骤就相当合乎逻辑了，你可以把事情安排到位。但就2024年修复你的财务而言，完成一份预算计划，知道你有什么。接下来的步骤就相当合乎逻辑了。你可以把事情安排到位。但就2024年修复你的财务而言，完成一份预算计划。知道你有什么进账、出账。让你的钱为你工作。
Make your money work in terms of getting money on your money in terms of compound growth that we've talked about. By understanding what you've got coming in and going out, you can give everything a job. You can understand what that's going to do for you. Link that to those five bits that we've just talked about there. And don't be afraid to make mistakes. You don't have to have a rigid plan that you have to stick to 100% every single day of the week, every single month, because you'll be miserable.
让你的钱为你工作，即通过我们谈到的复利增长来获得收益。通过了解你的进账和出账，你可以给每一分钱分配一个工作。你可以理解它将为你做什么。把它与我们刚才谈到的那五点联系起来。不要害怕犯错。你不必有一个必须每天、每个月100%坚持的僵化计划，因为那样你会很痛苦。
Give yourself a little treat every now and again. Have a little bit of a blowout. Come back to it, reset the clock, start again. If it fails once, come back and nail it again. If it fails two times, come back every now and again. Have a little bit of a blowout. Come back to it. Reset the clock. Start again. If it fails once, come back and nail it again. If it fails two times, come back and do it again. You can start again tomorrow. It doesn't make a difference if you don't quite get it this month, but just constantly keep that wheel moving forward,
偶尔给自己一点小奖励。稍微挥霍一下。回到正轨，重置时钟，重新开始。如果失败了一次，回来再做一次。如果失败了两次，偶尔回来。稍微挥霍一下。回到正轨。重置时钟。重新开始。如果失败了一次，回来再做一次。如果失败了两次，回来再做一次。你明天可以重新开始。如果你这个月没有完全做到，也没关系，但要不断地让那个轮子向前转动，
even just a little bit. Celebrate the little wins. Like 10 a month, great. You've started. Amazing. I could just keep going there's loads of tips i could give yeah absolutely maybe we need to do that for another one it's such good advice thank you so much for giving your time so freely so there we have it do go over
哪怕只是一点点。庆祝小小的胜利。比如一个月10英镑，太棒了。你已经开始了。太神奇了。我可以一直说下去，我有很多建议。是的，绝对的，也许我们需要为此再做一期，这真是很好的建议，非常感谢你如此慷慨地贡献你的时间。所以，就是这样，一定要去
and follow the lovely ian um on linkedin he um has great social posts over there and I often get myself into some very interesting conversations, but he really gets me thinking. Obviously, do get in contact with Ian if you wanted to look at engaging his services for your financial planning. You know, you can learn a lot simply by following him and being in his world. So have you got any future special request episodes that you'd like to see me cover? Because that is how this episode came about. Do come and let me know. Follow me over on any social channel. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere.
关注可爱的伊恩，在LinkedIn上，他那里有很棒的社交帖子，我经常发现自己陷入一些非常有趣的对话中，但他真的让我思考。显然，如果你想聘请他的服务进行财务规划，一定要联系伊恩。你知道，仅仅通过关注他并进入他的世界，你就能学到很多。那么，你有什么希望我涵盖的未来特别请求剧集吗？因为这一集就是这样产生的。一定要来告诉我。在任何社交渠道上关注我。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。
If you're watching on YouTube, please do like and subscribe, maybe tell your friends about us as well. And there will be a QR code on screen that will take you to all of my social channels. If you're listening to this as an audio, please do just type in Dr. Marianne Trent to any of your social channels and I shall appear. You can also come and connect with me over in the Aspiring Psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And yeah, if you do value this content, please do consider making a donation. And there are details for that in the show notes. You might also find the books, The Clinical Psychologist Collective and The Aspiring Psychologist Collective helpful. And of course, there is the Aspiring Psychologist membership too. Thank you so much for being part of my world. And I will
如果你在YouTube上观看，请点赞并订阅，也许也告诉你的朋友们。屏幕上会有一个二维码，可以带你去我所有的社交渠道。如果你是在听音频，请在你的任何社交渠道上输入Dr. Marianne Trent，我就会出现。你也可以在Aspiring Psychologist community with Dr. Marianne Trent与我联系。是的，如果你确实重视这些内容，请考虑捐款。节目说明中有详细信息。你可能还会发现《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家集体》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）这两本书很有帮助。当然，还有有抱负的心理学家会员资格。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我将
look forward to bringing the next episode to you from 6am on Monday. Take care. Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
期待在周一早上6点为你带来下一集。保重。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在身边，你将在成为合格心理学家的道路上。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Dr. Marianne Trent。我叫Jana，我是一名心理健康实习医生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的成为心理学家的方法，这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。